hey what's going on it's bill bird it's
time for the thursday afternoon just
before friday monday morning podcast and
ah
i'm just checking in on you
just checking in on you
seeing how your life's going you know
something
i have such an amazing life i feel like
it's time to give back to you guys
you know i'm just sitting here going
thinking to myself what could be better
than flying to indianapolis in the
middle of december
you know
patriots are playing the colts at lucas
oil field
stadium there
right
the game starts at seven my show starts
at seven i can't go to the [ __ ] game
you know what's even better
what is even better
is i have a [ __ ] cult
i mean this is the life that i am living
right now and i feel guilty and i want
you guys to know that at some point in
the future i am going to give back but i
want credit now
for just
having had the thought
that i'm thinking about you guys on some
level i really am my heart
breaks for everyone
out there
you know
because
sorry i live out here in l.a and the
weather's great and we never get cold i
just made me think
who am i to complain that i'm going to
indianapolis with a cold there are
people that have to live there
year round with colds
i'm [ __ ] with you indianapolis is
actually one of the ones uh
i like the highway system is extremely
confusing they got a giant [ __ ]
freeway that goes all the way around it
you don't know which way you're going
you're looking at the sun you're like
henry hill looking for helicopters
you're trying to figure out what which
way you're [ __ ] going
but um
downtown area a little scary
you know a little less foot traffic than
i would like one of those ghost town
kind of things but when it's open
when it's open all them corn fed people
are walking around
last time i went there with versi they
got a i know they have a really good
cigar bar somewhere out there
i also know that they got this famous
place where you go to get prime rib
and they have uh horseradish extra
horseradish on that [ __ ] uh
i can never say horseradish without
saying that since i watched the wire
um when he was confessing to all those
murders
[Laughter]
um
yeah i might do that it just sucks that
i have a [ __ ] colt because uh i gotta
i gotta i gotta tell you something here
like i have my my ancestors are from
that part of the country when my
ancestors came over here the joinments
they all settled in i think in indiana
or whatever so um
you know there was a farm or something
we had out there for many many years
and i think like 20 years ago
my mother asked me said it was going up
for salem for the first time in
i don't know like 100 years it wouldn't
be in our family name did i want to buy
it and i didn't have the [ __ ] money
also it's like paul sorvino and the
[ __ ] uh
goodfellas like oh well what do i know
about running a farm
um
he bought the farm what did that always
mean he bought the farm did that mean
you you were always in debt your whole
life and then when you died your life
insurance you finally were able to pay
off your farm is that what it meant
let's look it up shall we
but i like indiana it's kind of like
wisconsin without the serial killers
they don't have as many lakes but you
know you can take comfort in knowing
that your neighbor isn't going to make
uh you know turn you into a lamp after
he's done [ __ ] your corpse
uh that's wisconsin but you know
wisconsin has great milkshakes
do you know what i mean they're not like
michigan driving cars into [ __ ]
parades or was that wisconsin i get them
confused at this point you know you
would you wouldn't think there was
anybody nice in wisconsin or michigan
the way the f or any place the way the
[ __ ] news covers it
all right
he bought the farm
expression origin
there we go here we go
what is it meant by the phrase bought
the farm it comes from a 1950s era air
force term meaning to crash
or to be killed in action and it refers
to the desire of many wartime pilots to
stop flying return home
buy a farm and live peaceful
peaceably ever after wow i was 100 wrong
what a surprise
air force term mean to crash or to be
killed in action and refers to the
desire
of many wartime pilots to stop flying
well who wants to fly when you get
[ __ ] shot at
are you dropping bombs on people going i
hope they landed on the right ones
return home
buy a farm and live peaceably ever after
oh so they were just oh he bought the
farm
i get it where where is he i bought the
acting as though he went home to live
his dream when he really died
wow let's here's another one to see uh
new york times march 1954 a related play
in the glossary of jet pilot slang
bought a plot had a fatal crash
oh there's a bunch of different
explanations here
simple past tent and past particle to
buy the farm died often refers to the
death in battle or by plane crash it's
definitely
it's definitely uh there's a number of
theories
he bought the farm some funny bastard
said that on the air force base and now
nobody knows where it came from isn't
that interesting
isn't that interesting and this is what
i mean by giving back is i'll say things
and i won't know what they mean and then
i'll look them up for you
is that giving back i don't understand
um so anyway i'm coming out there to
indy and uh
indianapolis i've always had such weird
experiences when i go there obviously if
you know if you listen to any podcast
you know i sat next to that guy who
fancied himself to be part of the cia
kept asking me why i was going to
indianapolis and
press the button while we were taxing to
try and stop us from going somewhere
um
and then when i got to indianapolis one
time
i remember i was playing this theater
there was two theaters in the same
building
and the uh
the one downstairs was the smaller one
that was the one that i was playing and
the one upstairs was sesame street live
and uh
but but we shared the same stairwell
maybe it was next door and all i know is
like
the door opened to where they were and i
saw bert and ernie and all these guys i
was like oh [ __ ] and i filmed them
and bert starts walking towards me and i
thought he was waving like hello
they're like oh hey bert's coming over
to say hello
you know doing his laughing [ __ ] and he
came walking up i thought he was waving
he was doing the stop filming thing and
he slammed the door in my face
this giant bert he was like [ __ ] you
know with the
the big [ __ ] head and all that he
shut the door on my face and i was just
like oh [ __ ]
i guess ernie really is the cool one
right
so i ended up posting the video and then
the sesame street people got back to me
and said i didn't own the rights to the
video i had to take so i took it down i
said what do you [ __ ] mean i don't
own the [ __ ] rights to it you [ __ ]
it's my cell phone i had a right to be
there and you should have closed your
green room door get mad at bert
you know
oh bart was the only one on it ernie was
over there [ __ ] around but whatever
they were all in there and uh somewhere
on one of my laptops i still have that
um
video but this is what kills me you know
everybody's taking video and you take
all these [ __ ] pictures to your kids
and everything and then they update the
[ __ ]
it looks clear and it looks great then
they update the phones and then your
picture isn't worth the [ __ ] anymore
so like
i don't understand what what are you
supposed to be doing here like i'm
taking all these pictures to save them
what so they'll be all like pixelated
and it's like back to the future and
people are fading away all these videos
that i'm taking in my kids
i don't know it's weird
um
my daughter said something [ __ ]
hilarious today
i was driving into school and she goes
hey dad
she goes sometimes uh
sometimes lepers want to be alone and
they climb trees
[Music]
and i'm like lepers she goes yeah lepers
i go i think you mean leopards
she goes no it's leprous
and i was thinking all right well you
know they got that [ __ ] skin disease
they're shunned by society
i kind of like that that's a strong move
by a leper well i don't [ __ ] need you
either i'm going to go up here and sit
in this [ __ ] tree
you know this tree doesn't judge me
well even if it did it doesn't have the
option not to it's just for just sort of
standing there
jesus christ i always think that
whenever there's a christmas tree
the day that they come up with the
technology
to hear trees screaming
oh my god
that's gonna be the end of christmas
just a [ __ ]
you get your christmas tree right after
thanksgiving like i do in an entire
month what'd you do to my legs
ah
water
[ __ ]
actually understand those things
you know
and god created trees too and he allows
that [ __ ]
he made us smart enough to [ __ ] chop
him down
he just doesn't care i i really firmly
believe in that that whatever it is just
sort of made us in the left
like all right we'll see how that works
out then he went on to another world
you know
he
went on to another world i really think
god is a man by the way
i really do
just for the simple fact that we get
[ __ ]
done we don't stand around talking about
doing stuff and bitching about it and
trying to manipulate other people around
you to get you to do the job for them
you know that's not what a man does
it's what a woman does
i mean what have women accomplished ever
in history and you can't talk about
giving birth because you can't help that
if there was a way for you to make me
pregnant instead of you you would have
all right now i'm not trying to be like
sexist here i'm just trying to open a
dialogue
what are you talking about we've done
plenty of things
i'll tell you what my wife does she
[ __ ] puts up with me um which is not
easy
not easy oh [ __ ] grumpy bill with the
goddamn cold um
oh look who it is it's noob
you know when it comes to losing weight
there's a lot of pressure out there to
label foods good or bad but that just
creates unnecessary dilemmas noom
is here to change how we see food with a
psychologically based approach that
looks at what you eat
but also how you eat instead of making
you feel guilt or regret
noom empowers you to keep going
finish that gallon of ice cream instead
of trying to cram your life into someone
else's idea of health try noom new muse
is a psychological psycho
psychology-based approach to find a
healthier balance that's
moldable to your life this is what i
need right here and as a result more
sustainable instead of doing the diet
and then getting off the diet and then
gaining all the weight back and then
some you don't need rules to lose weight
just the knowledge and wisdom to empower
you to build smarter more sustainable
habits news weight cognitive behavioral
approach helps you better understand
your relationship with food how to be
more mindful of your habits it gives you
the knowledge and support you need for
long-lasting change 75 percent of newm
users
finish the program and more than 60
percent of the users
engage with the program keep the weight
off for a year or more that's incredible
with noob take care of your health
taking care of your health is empowering
instead of stress inducing no need to
fear running the whole uh ruining the
whole program with one off day noom will
help you get back on track that's what i
need one off day and i [ __ ] stick my
head in the sand for 10 days all you
need is a daily 10-minute check-in no
grueling early morning or huge chunks of
your day start building better habits
for healthier long-term results sign up
for your trial at noom
m dot n-o-o-m.com slash mmp that's noom
n-o-o-m.com
mmp oh look who it is everybody it's
liquid death i love these guys death to
plastic
if you have one crack open a can i got
one but i'm not home right now liquid
death also donates 10 of the profits to
help kill plastic pollution forever this
is basically bottled water except it's
in an aluminum can why did it take us so
long to get here i don't know but this
is where we're at thank god for a
company like liquid death uh try to
think of something more hardcore
than killing plastic pollution spoiler
you can murder your thirst and kill
plastic pollution save the earth look
dope as hell with liquid death it takes
up to 1 000 years for a plastic bottle
to decompose
your plastic will outlive you yeah times
10 even if you are a hundred aluminum is
infinitely recyclable and actually
profitable for recycling facilities look
cool drinking a crisp tall boy filled
with fresh mountain spring water reduced
waste pollution plus it tastes better
than a plastic bottle it's just a
[ __ ] win it's a win-win-win situation
they say
um
you'll see these cans popping up
everywhere liquid death is available if
your local whole foods sprouts or
7-eleven or my refrigerator i always
keep it stocked but you uh but you know
that's not all now you can rock liquid
death merch
that crazy logo you know and love is
available on sweatshirts hats even
license plate holders and don't you dare
pay for shipping go to
liquiddeth.com to get free shipping on
all water and merch that's
liquiddeth.com
to get free shipping on all water and
merch grab some now at whole foods
sprouts are 7-eleven
um do it now and totally murder your
thirst you know i've been listening to
lately
i've been listening to a lot lately as
i've been listening to a bunch of def
leppard man what a [ __ ] band
that high and dry album i never really
listened to it because you know i'm such
like a fanboy if it wasn't on mtv i get
nervous to go in deeper cuts
that first [ __ ] uh
the first couple of songs there let it
go and
hit and run
[ __ ] killer
absolutely killing i just love the
lyrics too
you know before all those
goddamn miserable [ __ ] seattle people
came in
jesus christ
what a bunch of mopey [ __ ] they were
huh
no one ever talks about that they always
just talk about how great the music is
that is true but those were not exactly
the most uplifting [ __ ] people he
ever wanted to be around
right
i know i've talked about this before but
those people in those [ __ ] you know
metal bands on the la sunset strip you
know they had a lot of [ __ ] up [ __ ]
happen to them too they didn't dump
their [ __ ] day on you
they kept it light
don't need nothing but a good time
[Music]
and they went back and they did their
heroine in private
let me tell you about the rock stars of
the 80s they were gentlemen
they were raised right you don't talk
politics
you don't talk religion you don't bring
up your sad [ __ ] childhood
you know of course they talk about some
broad every rose has its thought they
talk about some woman right
what was that what was that uh
oh what was that bad they [ __ ]
finally broke through with their hair
was it l.a guns
that song something about jane it was
always jane
jade says
and then what's his face sing about uh
mary jane everybody was thinking about
jane that was a popular name for a
troubled woman back then
at least a [ __ ] groupie
like if you named your daughter jane
in the 60s
50s or 60s there was a
good chance
that she was gonna blow a rock star
i think that that's why that name died
out
right
i don't know
i have no idea you know what i was doing
yesterday as i'm [ __ ] trying to get
over this goddamn cult
um
i put on the mlb network and i was
watching nolan ryan throw his last
no-hitter i think it was his last he was
44.
i was just seeing all these old-school
names
you know
tom house
somebody told you their name was tom
house she'd be like that's not a real
name
it's too simple and easy to remember
you know
nothing about that name shines a light
back onto the parents that's why you
give your kid an interesting name right
soliloquy
soliloquy oh my god
your daughter's name is soliloquy
what yeah
we call her ukui for short ukui
oh queen sorry oakwee
that's amazing now do you act
yes i do i recently had a project
meanwhile soliloquy's getting [ __ ]
the [ __ ] kicked out of her
does that even happen now there's too
many cameras
i wonder if old bullies talk to young
bullies now and they reminisce about how
easy it was to [ __ ] violate somebody
back in the day
ah man you bullies got rough today back
in the day you punch whoever the [ __ ]
you wanted to
the smaller the better
nobody said nothing
they all they would do was yell at the
victim and say you gotta learn how to
fight back those were the days
i tell you on a good day i'd slug six
[ __ ] third graders
before lunchtime
oh you know what i'm talking about right
now people i'm just thinking about i got
to get on a [ __ ] airplane oh jesus
christ
you know of everything that i've seen
in sci-fi movies the one thing that i
wish they could come up with was the
ability to zap yourself from one part of
the world to another
jesus christ you think this coven's out
of control now
uh but just for travel
can you imagine that but you could
literally live in los angeles and work
every day in london you just have to get
up earlier
right now i could just walk through a
[ __ ] porthole
out under the streets of beautiful
downtown indianapolis you know we got
the 500 out here
right
that's another great thing the
indianapolis 500 out there in indiana
you know i was trying to see if they had
any classic car shows but they don't
have that this time of year they got a
couple of dealerships out there
i [ __ ] love those things you know
i've been following lately you know old
trucks and all that [ __ ] now i'm kind of
into like those
you know those company cars
that a guy making a certain amount of
income used to drive
like the lincoln mark iv mach 4
was it mark or mark
lincoln mach 4. four times the speed of
sound and that sled i don't think so i'm
gonna say it was mark four
um
the silver
something edition
that's when they had that that buttoned
leather seat whatever they call it
where that button would push all the
leather in it was absolutely stunning
guys would get that car in silver and
have like either silver interior or
they'd have a red leather interior
they'd [ __ ] drive down the street in
a goddamn cloud
and they'd eat steaks and they'd smoke
cigars and they'd drop of a heart attack
at 58 but they were living
uh
the mercury grand marquis
you know
like they don't make cars they don't
really like make luxury cars anymore it
seems like everything goes fast
or it looks badass but i'm trying to
think of like a fat ass [ __ ]
you know boss hog car
i know jaguar has one jaguar has one bmw
has like the seven series
um
let me see here
luxury sedans let's see who's making one
now they'll probably say like a lexus
nothing like drives like a sports car
audi a8
lexus is mercedes-benz
yeah all of these cars like hall ass
those [ __ ] luxury cars back in the
day
like they couldn't even get out of their
own [ __ ] way
it was all about just cruising down the
road
you didn't want to drive fast you wanted
everybody to see how much money you were
making
yeah you had to drive slow enough
so you could meet the eye of some broad
walking down the [ __ ] street and she
knew
she saw that [ __ ] leather interior
and she's like oh my god those pockets
are deep over there baby
[ __ ] pockets are deep over there man
i don't know if you're wondering if i'm
slowly losing my mind during all of this
[ __ ] you're right i am
i am
i know i'm gonna have good shows though
i do know that now where the [ __ ] is my
reads for this week
oh jesus i don't have any reads i don't
have any advertising or was there
somebody that i upset did something
happen
well well there you go i do have to i do
have to tease this i did a thursday
afternoon just before friday monday
morning podcast
um with
jim gaffigan a month ago
and it starts off with talk and comedy
and by the end i was only supposed to do
a half hour i think we did like an hour
and a half or hour and 45 minutes we
were just trashing each other
and it was the [ __ ] most fun i've had
with another comic in a long long time
and jim has a new special coming out on
netflix so
next monday
i will be uh
i'm actually taking the day off because
i
um
recorded that thing a month ago
which is kind of an interesting idea for
me
i should start doing that more often
pre-recording a guest and then because
what's now what's happening is when i go
to indianapolis i don't have to bring my
podcast [ __ ]
it's the little victories people
you know when i go through security what
is that is that a weapon it's a
microphone why do you have a microphone
because i do a podcast oh really why do
you do a podcast because i'm lonely
because i wasn't good at math i don't
know
why do you rummage through people's bags
because i'm saving your [ __ ] life
all right fair enough
fair enough i get it
there's no reason to get hostile
you know what's great about having a
cold and telling people about it on the
podcast is that you get to
learn all everybody's [ __ ] cold
remedies
i need a remedy remedy remedy
um
i remember once a long time ago somebody
said the second you blow your nose
that's when you get the cold
so if you just don't blow your nose it's
just like
are you really that [ __ ]
stupid
um you know laying down right now is not
working for me
it really isn't
all right let's look out for cold
remedies
cold remedy
i've got gonna sneeze
i'm gonna sneeze
shortens duration less than severity of
cold backed by science well it says it's
backed by science it's gotta work
that's the only way to blow your nose on
a podcast is you just have to commit to
it
you gotta commit to it
umka
nature's way
uh make your way to feeling better with
homeopathic ingredients and a variety
i'm god this [ __ ] doesn't work
none of this [ __ ] this somebody cured
the [ __ ] cold you know what i'm
saying if somebody actually cured this
[ __ ] you'd never hear the end of it
you know if i was president right now
okay and i was aware that i was actually
president
like this guy that we have you know
which by the way paul versus has the
greatest thing there there should be an
age limit about when you can be
president
you know i think like 55
is a great age
you know you can't be too young
because then you like bill clinton just
banging [ __ ] in the pool and you're
not getting anything done you got to be
like 55
you're on the other side of it
you know
but you're not like
i don't know
like some fossil like like trump and
this [ __ ] guy joe biden right you
need like 55.
maybe that's how they do it
you can only be president if you're 55
to 63
and you're a man
that's it right
hey by the way
i don't want to get petty here but when
was the last time there was a bald
president
let me see this here
let's see let's look this up this this
is how i use the internet the last bald
president
okay
let me see oh now they're getting so
good with those those goddamn hair
systems
all right search search for the [ __ ]
thing
the president and board kind
of jesus christ
did i have to say of the united states
do you remember that band the president
of the united states
i forget something that has something
then i [ __ ] something that i [ __ ]
said
oh it said bored
bald
honey how are you bald and you don't
know how to spell it the last bald
president of the usa
let's see
dwight d eisenhower
great call
it has been nothing but hair ever since
the last bald president almost goes back
as far as the last time the maple leafs
won the stanley cup i'm sorry to
everyone in toronto i'll be there next
summer
dwight
david
eisenhower
or david dwight eisenhower he went by
dwight
you know
if he was president today they'd call
him white eisenhower
how many bulbs
how many ball presidents have there been
let's see i bet there was a lot more of
them back in the day when they didn't
have hair systems
you know
back when ben franklin thought he looked
good
i know he wasn't a president but you
know
it's kind of like with baseball like how
back in the day when it was just white
people
and they played without baseball gloves
and [ __ ] like three guys a year would
hit 400
then it became one guy every three years
and then it just became ted williams did
it in 1946 and no one ever did it again
that's like bald presidents all right
three for a proper answer we would have
to define what we mean by bald and
specifically you know what it is the
[ __ ] horseshoe
i define bald as having no hair at the
highest point of the skull
okay
okay john quincy adams bald
martin van buren bald
dwight eisenhower bald
honorable mentions
john tyler
he was starting to lose it he was
hanging in there james polk
i wouldn't dude that's a [ __ ] he
looks like a poet
james garfield is bald
he absolutely is bald
warren g harding
nah he looks like the [ __ ] head of
chrysler
calvin coolidge
yeah all these guys are just losing it
herbert
hoover
james garfield and rutherford b hayes i
don't know
man that's some names that all died out
is there one [ __ ] normal name into
that it just that fascinates me
ma ed martin van bruin buren
dwight dwight said dwight howard
john
john 13 316 they're still quoting his
work james that stuck around another
james
warren
warren potsie weber's the last warren
that i knew calvin
that's a cart that's a cartoon now
calvin herbert
you know
you could have that as a last name to be
the quarterback of the charges but
nobody has that [ __ ] name there's
another james rutherford
jesus christ
chester
chester you need a man you need a
[ __ ] horse chester
rutherford b hayes
that is a great fake [ __ ] name
you know if you ever slip into a party
that you're not supposed to be at you're
kind of getting busted when they ask you
what your [ __ ] name is you should go
by rutherford
don't say be haze they don't [ __ ]
you'll get caught
rutherford h salisbury
one of those
blue blood names
even they went away from those [ __ ]
blue blood names huh
they were getting all [ __ ] nervous
you can tell by your name how much money
you have
blue this last thing i'm going to look
up and then mercifully end this podcast
blue blood names
blue blood names we'll be right back
with blue blood names
that's hilarious it says tom selleck
donnie wahlberg i guess there's a
there's a show called blue bloods
49 preppy baby names oh i love it
let's make it let's let's go nice and
white here what do we got here
digby
oh digby jesus christ that's just
someone you know
even look at him his family's gonna
[ __ ] sue you no matter what he does
he hits you with his car and he sues you
for debt in his [ __ ] car there's
nothing you can do
connery
ingram
yates
that's a [ __ ] name
aldrich
whitaker
another worker i knew was lou whitaker
bronwyn
thompson
tilly
oh tilly you [ __ ] stuck up c note
teague
niles
i like niles
orson
merritt
margot with an aux
bradford
palmer darcy
tinsley poppy
ellison vance
thatcher
briggs briggs is a good [ __ ] name
briggs
briggs is an unusual name choice for
baby boys brings us an old english name
that translates to bridges
that's a [ __ ] strong name briggs
it's a name and a nickname all at the
same time
tiger stadium used to be brick stadium
kingsley
blaine blair
you take the good you take the bad you
take them both in there you have the
facts of life quincy
now they're going all old school shows
here blair quincy
roland
great drums electronic drums best
electronic drums in the business
okay i'll read two more lennox
enlightened
sterling davis keaton sloan ainsley reed
brooks
finley corbin sorry i can't stop graham
emerson
tucker
there's a lot of tuckers
all right
speaking of tucker i am tuckered out
from this podcast i don't know how i do
it people but i always land on my feet
before we get out of here
let's uh you know me and paul verzie a
couple of degenerate gamblers
um
we do the bet mgm segment each week
where me and paul versi pick four nfl
games and not like these bums on these
other sports shows where they're betting
the money line we bet against the spread
like a real man does it
and so far this year me and paul versi
we are like
combined we're both over 500 against the
spread
14 [ __ ] weeks in so you do the
goddamn you do the [ __ ] math that's
56 [ __ ] games
and we're still up on bet mgm and you
could be too if you listen to the two
bald idiots you're about ready to listen
to right now
what's up everybody and welcome back to
the anything better nfl preview show
sponsored by bet mgdm you guys know we
use bet mgm the most reliable lines in
the betting game okay if you haven't
signed up yet we've got a special offer
for our listeners with bet mgm you sign
up uh a new bet mgm account and use
bonus code burr that's b-u-r-r like it's
always been it's very simple and you'll
get 50 free bet just for signing up guys
you're going to get 50. that's right you
don't even need to make a deposit to get
in on the action
if you haven't signed up yet it's very
simple go to bedmg uh use code bur get
fifty dollars off and uh that's it bet
to use for this week's games as a
reminder bet mgdm is finally coming to
louisiana while sports betting isn't
live quite yet you could sign up early
for bet mgm just use bonus code bur for
200 free bets no deposit required to uh
use uh sports betting live in louisiana
now i love that they held out made sure
they got the best deal
now we are going into
this is what's going on here okay
because i was actually thinking about
this i was actually thinking about this
and and i'm pretty impressed okay now
bill
is a little more i would say this i
don't want to speak for him but bill's a
little slightly more humble than me
uh
now i would say rightly
you know bill listen i don't do a crazy
nfl touchdown dance bill hands the ball
right off to the official i i do a quick
thing i have to do a quick thing i don't
do no i don't do a full break dance no
but yeah because you can't
but if you could you would
but let's just talk
like you're holding back paul
let's just talk about what's going on
here okay so after week 14
after week 14 with us picking four games
a week against the spread going into
week 15 okay
bill burr
31 24 and one he went two and two last
week
he
stayed even so he's where he stayed over
500 me i did gain a game going three and
one and i am 29 and 27. that means guys
with three weeks left and i got a
message from a fan saying you and burr
are making me money that is guys
we somebody said i am riding the
anything better train and you two are
making you're gonna jinx it paul
you're waking him up you gotta keep it
quiet
so we want to thank everybody for
following us
no we want to thank everybody what did i
say what did i say don't buy anything
take it back taking my mom pulling up in
the pink cadillac with the [ __ ] fur
coat on bill it's in my mother's name
uh i love that car can i read an email
from a listener
yeah yes
as a real go and good morning uh big fan
of the podcasts i listen while i'm
walking
out each morning at 4 30 a.m i wish you
were on every day i'm a 77 year old
great grandmother i don't use the f word
however i'm excusing you because you're
a sweetheart of a guy and i understand
more you understand more about what
makes women tick than any man i've known
and i've known this went into the bills
podcast paul i'm sure you know a lot
about women i don't want you to feel
left out here uh listen he was about to
listen to your picks and made a
three-team parlay between this weekend
my husband placed the bed for me
washington colts and cardinals won them
on your advice my husband was impressed
just a bit because she teased it up
because cardinals didn't win 77 year old
grandmother thank you donna
wow
wow she took and she took she took your
cardinals bet and my washington bet and
teased it and ended up winning
oh my god
like you know what bill this is why no
one's going to take notice of what we're
doing because they're you know we're
first year they're going to say these
are first-year jerk-offs not knowing so
we need to come back next year and
continue this but make no mistake what
we are doing is pretty deep enemies
bring them on dude bring them on
um they're going to say no everybody
said we couldn't do it man
so now here we go we're going into week
15.
we're going into week 15 bill
uh like i said bill is thirty one twenty
four one well i am in the uh i'm in a
prevent defense knowing you're coming
i'm just trying to give up the middle of
field and only lose one game a week and
hopefully i'll [ __ ] be there at the
end i don't like this week at all
all right let's go who goes first this
week uh this is an odd week so this
would be me
all right who do you like i know you
like
oh boy
well hold on a second andrew can we just
get confirmation is baker mayfield out
with covet i heard that just now and if
that's the case that's a big deal for
cleveland because they're they're
playing a not so good raiders team right
now but if baker's out i'm done
um
he's out right not confirmed he's likely
out
dude covet covets getting players in all
the leagues wild
um all right see
throws a wrench in there
hey you know it's funny they wear face
masks on sunday they can't do it during
the week can they
all right
you know what i found nothing on the
table
this is this isn't i'm sorry no no i'm
just i'm just trying to
i'm just trying to to get this going on
here um
you getting it going on paul yeah see i
don't know i'm not even speaking right
you know what guys i'm gonna have to do
it i'm gonna ride the train and here's
why
the green bay packers are minus four
against the ravens but lamar jackson
might be out and the thing is
green bay needs to keep winning to get
that home field because the bucks can
keep [ __ ] [ __ ] what is this all
this these guys might be in they might
be out what the [ __ ] am i betting on
here
i know well lamar jackson it wasn't cold
some chick's instagram picture you don't
know what she looks like till she shows
up she [ __ ] held the camera up here
she comes in she's a [ __ ] whale paul
that reminds me of bartnik's joke when
he says they just show their eyes he
goes those are fat eyes um all right i'm
going to take the green bay packers
i'm going to take the green bay packers
minus four and a half on the road
against the ravens holding home field
advantage
all right
it's beginning to look a lot like 2001
i'm taking the new england patriots
getting two and a half at lucas oil
field uh playing indianapolis i will be
there saturday night when they're
playing but i'll be doing two shows
cause when you're in show business you
miss everything
everybody's sitting around eating a
[ __ ] pot roast and you're out there
mammy how i love you how i love you
mammy that's the sacrifice you make
lucas oilfield my [ __ ] team is right
down the street i am in that godforsaken
city with that [ __ ] highway that goes
all the way around it you forget which
way you're going you know it's like
you're in the blair wish you remember
that they're running around the woods
scott was that his name
dougie
i i don't remember that but i remember
the player witch no i don't show her
that's why you forget her
no yeah
i remember running nose
footage that movie scared the [ __ ] out
of me i saw it by myself at a midnight
show
uh
remember all these dumb comics man that
movie didn't scare me at all geez you're
so [ __ ] tough in a movie theater
i was petrified i was scared because the
way they labeled the movie the way they
previewed it was that it really happened
and i was like oh [ __ ] man these kids
got
um
you know what
it's weird
it's weird that the cults are two and a
half favorites against the pats um i'm
not touching that because carson wentz
scores points they got that running back
i mean you know
we'll see what happens we've had a
couple of push-ups off he's had two
weeks to prepare for him paul
look i see what you're doing you're
gonna go head-to-head against me paul
you're no no this is the hail mary
i could have got how mad would you have
been if i picked the patriots first i
don't like the game and i don't like the
fact that the colts are minus
[ __ ] all over the game that i just
picked what [ __ ] game did you
i don't pick that game either he's going
into [ __ ] baltimore somebody's gonna
go out and get some crab cakes and get
coven they're not gonna be able to block
[ __ ] aaron rodgers blind side how do
you like that i just [ __ ] all over noah
touche why am i talking about your bet i
should be concentrated on my bet you're
absolutely right i'm stalling bill i'm
stalling
um you know when you say touche
touche yeah is that when you say it
though
yeah too shameful to say like fair
enough
i thought if you were like you know
arguing about history your country's
better than my accountability
sushi and fair enough is kind of one and
the same i don't think it is
yeah it is no that's exactly what it is
fair enough we're just [ __ ] hanging
out
touche means you're right fair enough
means i guess you're right it's kind of
close i mean what are we going to agree
oh too [ __ ]
good point all right you know let's keep
doing this so i could stall
um you know this is so weird why are the
broncos favorite against the bengals
after the bengals
um because the bengals have been
[ __ ] the bedpole
and laying in it and rolling around
their own waste
i'm taking the los angeles rams
after seeing that front four on sunday i
like that the hapless seattle seahawk
the seahawks are done
the seahawks are
done
it's over yeah when russell will you
said the chiefs were done paul
chiefs are done
look at you there's not nearly as much
confidence you like they are a bad
football team i told you i said you
never know
they could wake up they're starting to
wake up paul i'm gonna take the rams
it's minus four and a half at home
against the flailing
hapless seattle seahawks petey sneaky
pete has half make no mistake about this
sneaky pete has already talked to a real
estate agent his one leg is out the door
and he's looking for his new home you
think i'm that bad
they're done dude
they're with him and they ship russell
wilson out and i think he goes to new
york because he wants the people to
[ __ ] go nuts when he scores a
touchdown everybody knows if you do
something great out in [ __ ] seattle
the half the country's asleep by the
time you did it
all right i got
rams minus four and a half at home what
do you got
hey
first of all i gotta get i'm getting a
[ __ ] attitude from you
all right relax
i got this what do you got i'll [ __ ]
take my time just like you do
i got you at least
getting two points
against the pittsburgh steelers
yeah i don't like that game
titans are given why are you [ __ ]
all over my bets
no no because i always go for tennessee
you know that i just i was afraid
you took the ball good for you
good for you i didn't have the balls i
really didn't have the balls i don't try
and act like you you're being cut you
know what it is paul this is a
competitive side of you you could still
win paul you don't have to [ __ ] on all
my bets
on the i was just gonna put the jigs on
all my bets it's annoying
no such thing what are you going to say
now fair enough because you already used
touche
titans are given too by the way they're
giving too dude the only time you see an
ugly side of paul verzi is during
competition
no that's not true he gets this look on
his face and you go wow he really is
sicilian
he is like mentally whacking me right
now
it's beginning to look a lot like
christmas
i'm going to take joe burrow
i'm going to take gerber joe burrow and
the cincinnati bengals getting two and a
half they just lost a heartbreaker at
home
and this is their season
uh against the denver broncos so give me
the bangles plus two and a half they
have to be in this game they have to win
this game hey paul guess what i like
that pick
all right
here's a game that we're both ignoring
paul
the houston texas versus the
jacksonville jaguars
those are bill's picks who those are
those are two teams bill always bets
with whoever was playing them and now
they're playing each other
you've been on them you've been on them
come on don't just make that all about
me i don't know why i'm gonna do this
paul
why would i do i'm gonna wait i'm gonna
think about that one
uh
i'll go head to head with you if you
like the job for you i'm gonna take the
kansas city chiefs
oh cause i think you're wrong paul
i think at the end of the day patrick
mahomes is one of the greats
okay and this is you know what the
greats do paul they step it up
they step it up in december in the end
of the day the san diego los angeles
chargers are still the san diego
chargers
just like caitlyn jenner still bruce
jenner
that's all the same just because you
[ __ ] move and become the los angeles
rams does not mean you weren't in st
louis and these [ __ ] they got that
san diego stink on them
qualcomm stadium
is still hanging over them until they
exercise that demon
i was gonna go head-to-head with you i
was gonna i was gonna take the charges
because justin herbert dude the kids on
another thing right now but
i just saw the buffalo bills minus 10
and a half at home after losing two
heartbreakers in a row they're playing
the panthers who are completely done
they took out cam newton again benched
him put another guy in ah geez i think
that would have helped i'm taking the
buffalo bills minus 10 and a half
at home to put an absolute [ __ ]
beating
on the carolina panthers they're going
to win that game probably by 20. there
it is
boof i almost took a head to head and
almost lost
but uh how do you know you almost almost
tell you know you almost lost
um
all right the minnesota vikings going
into chicago they're getting three and a
half points
i don't know anything about either one
of those teams but i know
i like their running back minnesota but
i also like the dallas cowboys getting
10 and a half given 10 and a half
going into the giants i mean you want to
talk about a [ __ ] team that's just
playing for [ __ ]
i don't know playing for a draft pick at
this point
probably unfortunately i'm going to go
with
but they always but they always [ __ ]
get up for the cowboys though
ten and a half is a lot of points paul
it's a lot of points giants are home
giants are home
i know that's a tough one are you gonna
take to new york are you gonna take my
new york football giants for the first
time since we've been doing this
no they're a [ __ ] mess dude
i'm going to go 0-4 this week i can feel
it
this is the thing right here that's
going to make me go on for do i take
minnesota or do i take
dallas
ah
dude [ __ ] the cowboys they're too
erratic
minnesota vikings [ __ ] it yeah i don't
like any of those picks except the pats
all right
um
that's it andrew though you beat me this
year the level of how not classy you're
going to be it's just going to be
disgusting that's just so not like are
you trying to prepare us like what are
you talking i'm the most gracious
what are you talking about i'm a good
sportsman dude that's in your head man
no that's in your head it isn't yes it
is i wouldn't do that we rammed it up
there [ __ ] answers i got you all the
way back in the day from the beginning
dude i was 26 or 27 when i said that to
you i was probably drunk and uh
hey kill's a grudge okay
no no no i've i've listened i've noticed
it
dude that's like an old guy
i hear it in your voice some of it might
be my own childhood [ __ ] but i hear it
in your voice paul something happens to
you when you compete it's funny the only
time you're not like santa claus i think
the childhood thing in your past is a
little more what it is i don't think so
because i just said that to you but now
you're just using that as an excuse if i
was looking forward to come up with it
no i was looking for a reason why you
think that and that makes more sense
because if you beat me i've been saying
the whole time you're on some other [ __ ]
right well if i ever had you my you be
if you beat me this year if i ever had
you miked up secretly in your [ __ ]
house
you'd owe me a phone call no no
you know you would i wouldn't take it
personal you know what do you think i
would say i would i would just be like
oh dude i [ __ ] you know what i was
saying yeah [ __ ] that orange
[ __ ] yeah
you've not it would paul it would that's
that's
i would never say [ __ ] that orange
[ __ ] you know what i would say
to be honest if i won
that loved me and my life has i you know
[Laughter]
all right guys there is our week 15.
here's the best part though win or lose
how about this i think this is a common
ground we could both agree on if me and
you both finish either 500 or above
that's what i want
that is a win in itself and that means
our listeners whether you win or lose
it's whether you [ __ ] beat the book
if we beat the book after amgm is going
down
if we beat the book after this whole
season
and we made some people some money they
can't say uh those guys don't know what
the [ __ ] they're doing i think they
always will they should send they should
issue a statement
yeah
we said it has been a long time since
two bald bastards over 17 weeks have
been able to pick four games a week and
be above 500.
all right uh that's it all right guys
this has been yes this has been the uh
week 15 preview oh that's right that's
right oh by the way every week right
paul
you know here's what happens here's what
happens when andrew themlast is in here
we do a great podcast and we don't hit
the record button so he's here now and
uh we almost missed the monday night
experience thinking of switching over to
dallas dude
i was so pissed off that we missed
another monday night special by one
thing bill bill's pick of the two stacks
by the cardinals happened stafford my
pick stafford happened
and then we were just waiting for a kyle
murray rush touchdown and it never
[ __ ] happened guys we're coming close
we didn't get it showed up to play when
they didn't push that guy over on that
first play and then the very next play
they called the penalty but he was all
over that guy again i was like oh jesus
aaron donald was not gonna be [ __ ]
denied that kid as an animal 99 on um
the you know for the people that don't
know his will he did he did but um
listen we did get you two two monday
night specials and we've come within one
thing of happening on three or four
monday nights but we don't need to
apologize
so bill i ask you now
so now i ask you would you care what the
son of a [ __ ] was wearing
what was that casino my cousin vinnie
um i never saw that movie when he was
gonna shoot a deer um all right monday
night is the vikings and the chicago
bears is that right uh yup andrew okay
what's the line
three and a half
minnesota's uh
giving three and a half that's the game
that bill just picked so you wanna i'm
giving no i'm getting
given minnesota is giving three and a
half
what
yeah it's minnesota minus three and a
half yeah
you want to change that last pick to the
cowboys
listen we're still on the show so you
could change that pick yeah whatever you
want to do bill let's add drama and i'll
change it so that everybody can [ __ ]
be into it but we should have kept it
but andrew you got to make sure you
write down the so we don't get yeah yeah
all right i'm going to take the cowboys
against your giants i'm sorry paul i
don't like you
i don't like doing that to you oh
[ __ ] you know what we got a backup
quarterback andrew what's his name is
out daniel jones they said is out again
ten and a half points is a lot with
barkley healthy but our offensive line
stinks
um i uh okay so i think that delvin
williams what the hell's his name what
what's oh dalvin cook dalvin cook
delvin williams played running back for
the dolphins in the 80s um i would
he's gonna he's gonna run one in
he will run one in he you run one in he
will run one in for sure who's their
left tackle i say they call the [ __ ]
he's eligible they throw it to him what
does that pay
uh
i don't like that i'm [ __ ] with you
oh
that comes in dude if that came in you
win
um all right so dalvin cook rushes for a
touchdown
you want to do kirk cousins over 250
yards passing or no
can you do that
oh no you know they're going to be
it's every 25 yards so it's got to be 25
50. i think it's going to be a boring
game
i don't know why
those two [ __ ] teams hate each other
it's the monsters of the midway versus
the [ __ ] [ __ ] up there and uh mall
of america and i just think that they
always play like
you know those are never like you know
40 to 38 games maybe they are but i
don't remember it
i i take the under we take the under
what's the under over on it 44 and a
half
right now it's 44 and a half by the time
it comes out it could could could move a
point but you know bears have a decent
defense
fighter all right i mean the bears just
gave up 45 points though
yeah do you [ __ ] dream boat guy there
aaron rodgers you got a poster of them
um
your bedroom wall
i'll go you know i'll go under if you
want to go under i don't know i don't
know if i like that paul i don't i
didn't even watch a second of football
last week i'm not gonna lie to you
i had [ __ ] to do
how about the game was off they had a
bye week why can't i have a bye week
justin fields let's do something with
justin fields oh he's one of the best
kickers in the nfl right no the one of
the he's the quarterback of the bears
like i said nobody slings it like that
guy
he's got legs you want can we do justin
fields russian for 50 yards
no that's a lot
40 yards
oh he said it's everything
these [ __ ] these two teams are in the
witness protection program i don't know
anybody on these [ __ ] tv
so how about this let's make it fun then
let's make it fun okay let's see over
vikings get an interception justin
field's gonna throw an interception so
vikings get an interception dalvin cook
gets a touchdown and then bill let's do
a bears one what do you want to do for
the bears there uh
three people have a heart attack in the
stance
sorry shout out to the snl sketch
um
i don't want to see here uh
so the quarterback of the bears throws a
pick dalvin cook rushes a touchdown
anybody in the bears is it mitch
trabitsky is he gone dude mitch
schmisky's been gone yeah yeah was he
playing the flamingo now
some reason i pictured him opening for
the osmonds
kirk cousins kirk cousins throws a
touchdown
yeah i also like the over [ __ ] this
let's say it's going to be an exciting
game
over
yeah
all right there you go we'll do over
so here you go for the people it's done
and the way people get up you know
people get confused i'm going to
reiterate
paul you say it again don't use big
words the over
we're going to go the over 44 and a half
is it 44.99 for 44.
andrew 44.5 for 44.
40 49. yeah over 44 and a half
galvin cook rush is a touchdown fair
enough
agree to disagree
[Laughter]
all right
it's billy sniffles over there
um
well while billy sniffles is getting a
tissue don't forget everybody please use
the bed mgdm app it's the best most
reliable alliance the best app to bet
with uh we love it and we love working
with them
and a woman
the difference between those with
kleenex guys use toilet paper
oh
i like that it's all paper right
this guy knows what i'm talking about
back me up i'm doing 80s comedy here
yeah and women go use the tissue it's
like just give me whatever i don't
[ __ ] use a i use it i use a towel
get me mad bill trying to round even you
and i had to back off the paper towel
you're done rubbing your nose you look
like you did a [ __ ]
did you look like you just got out of a
ufc fight
yeah you look like yeah you know bruised
up and [ __ ]
um
hey dude that chick beat that other the
brazilian check i missed it i know we
got to talk about that on the on the we
got to talk about that on the other one
all right let's drop that up here paul
down with my interruption i'm trying to
i'm trying to [ __ ] wrap it up and
then you're blowing your nose wait you
froze
bill froze did we lose bail okay he's
back um
all right guys so that's the uh
that's the deal what's that
that was funny because as i was frozen
you were going like i'm trying
and i'm saying all right did paul freeze
or did i freeze paul's trying to do
something but don't worry listeners the
suspense is killing me
well don't worry listeners because in
january we'll be out together in the atc
[ __ ] studio
i'm taking billy sniffles to dinner
taking feminists to dinner i'll buy
everybody [ __ ] dinner you think i
give a [ __ ] steaks on a kid steaks on
the kid all right here we go
if you guys haven't signed up yet all
right please use this offer we love
working with bet mgm their lines are the
best and uh listen you guys know mgm
it's the most reliable okay so we have
offers just for our listeners if you
sign up with ben mgm account and you use
bonus code burr you're gonna get fifty
dollars free just for signing up you're
going to get a 50
free bet just for signing up okay you
don't even that's right you don't even
have to you don't even need to make a
deposit to get any action if you haven't
signed up for bet mgm yet use bonus code
burp that's burr you'll get 50 free bet
to use for this week's game as a
reminder that mgm is finally coming to
louisiana that's right all you people
down there by you while sports betting
isn't live quite yet it's time uh you
could sign up early for bet mgm just use
a bonus code bur burr for 200 and free
bets no deposit required to use when
sports betting is live in louisiana we
love working with bet mgm they've been
the best and uh that's been the show
that has been our nfl preview show
going into week 15 and i'm gonna talk a
little [ __ ] we're beating the book and
we're gonna keep beating the book
how you like that till next week
visit betmgm.com for terms and
conditions 21 years of age or older to
wager arizona colorado dc iowa
indianapolis louisiana michigan missouri
new jersey nevada pennsylvania tennessee
virginia west virginia wyoming
washington only all promotions are
subject to qualification and eligibility
requirements rewards issued as
non-withdrawable free bets or site
credit free bets expire in seven days
from issuance excludes michigan
disassociated persons please gamble
responsibly gambling problem call 1-800
next step in arizona
1-800-522-4700 colorado dc louisiana
nevada wyoming virginia 1-800-270-711
for confidential help in michigan 1-800
gambler in indianapolis new jersey
pennsylvania and west virginia or 1-800
that's off in iowa call or text the
tennessee red line 800-889-9789
tennessee or call 1-888-777-9696
in missouri or 1-800-547-6133
for washington that's 1-800-547-6133
sports betting is void in georgia hawaii
ohio and utah and other states were
prohibited promotional offers not
available in nevada
all right that ends the bet mgm segment
for the week uh now we have a little
music bed here
um
that was picked out by the wonderful
they always they always wholesomely
always awesome one of the nicest people
you're ever going to meet in beverly
hills
andrew themless
and then we're going to have a bonus
episode of the uh
thursday afternoon just before friday
monday morning podcast and uh that'll be
it by the time you're done listening to
this i will be in indianapolis
smoking a cigar eating some prime rib
with some horseradish on that
[ __ ] all right i'll see you
[Music]
so i get on the [ __ ] plane right
i use my miles bump myself up like a
fancy person you know maybe maybe i
invented the cheesecake factory people
are thinking and then they see how i'm
dressed and they go oh no he didn't vent
the cheesecake factory
um
and i go to go to sit down in my seat
and i go to set my bag down i was going
to set it down right in front of me and
the nice fella sit next to me because
why don't you stick it in the middle
there's room and he moved his bag out of
the way i'm like all right this guy's a
solid dude or whatever and then all of a
sudden the waitress comes by
a stewardess whatever she comes by um
flight attendant whatever the [ __ ]
you're supposed to call him she comes up
and she uh could i get you gel away to
drake and i was like yeah can i get a
let me get a water please
ice or no ice what however you make it
stop acting like it's a [ __ ] martini
it's all right just give me a water with
ice thank you
um
and the the guy next to me he orders the
doors neat
no ice no nothing just put it in there
so they bring our drinks all right
and i'm really thirsty so i start
sucking mine down and he just throws his
back like it's nothing
like [ __ ] john wayne right before
he's gonna turn around and beat up three
guys three mustachioed guys in the 1930s
right
so um
i'm just sitting there and everybody's
getting on the flight you know and i'm
looking around at the passengers
you know i'm [ __ ] doing whatever i'm
doing and all of a sudden the guy next
to me mr dewars goes to me uh he goes
excuse me he goes are you afraid to fly
and i looked at him i was like what
he goes are you afraid to fly
and i go no
no i'm not
and he goes
he goes all right but you know it's he
goes it's okay you know
it's okay to tell me if you're afraid to
fly
and it's immediately getting weird
and i'm like no i'm not afraid to fly
and then i'm thinking in my head wait is
he afraid to fly
and that's why he's drinking the way he
just drank
and now he's hoping that i'm going to be
afraid to fly so he you know he just
wants to open up that's what i'm
thinking
and i'm like yeah no i'm not afraid to
fly
and he won't leave it alone he goes all
right because you know you're you're
you're
fidgeting you're looking around at other
passengers
and i'm sitting there looking at like is
this guy [ __ ]
serious and i go no
i go i'm not afraid to fly so now i'm
like [ __ ] this guy i'm not talking this
guy for the rest of the flight this
guy's weird man it's like 30 just give
paint to pictures like 32 year old wiry
in shape but like wiry white dude he's
got a skully cap on with [ __ ] glasses
um
you know
and uh
he goes uh
like there's like a minute of silence
and people are still getting on the
plane and then he goes hey sorry about
that sorry we just we just got off
on the uh wrong foot he's like my name's
so-and-so he goes what's your name
and then i'm thinking in my head like
what's my name my name's frank
i wanted to give him like a by just some
reason i just wanted it's bill
and he goes oh hey bill and he goes nice
to meet you so we shake hands
and i'm just looking i don't have any
poker face i'm looking at the guy like
what the [ __ ] is your problem i'm not
even trying to not i'm not trying to be
pleasant i'm already done with this guy
so then the guy goes oh hey bill he goes
why are you going to indianapolis bill
right like he's [ __ ] interrogating me
and i
i'm like is this guy [ __ ] serious
and i start doing the math in my head
going wait is this guy like an air
marshal or something i'm like no he's
not he's [ __ ]
slamming booze over here [ __ ] this guy
so i just go
go look i don't have to answer your
questions
that's it and i just look straight
forward
he goes okay now i'm concerned
okay
i am concerned and i'm looking at him
like
concerned about what
he goes you're fidgeting you you have
issues with other passengers and blah
blah blah he sucks peyton like like this
like he's been i don't know what the
[ __ ] like psychologically breaking me
down
all right so now just by this point
they've closed the [ __ ]
the door
to the fuselage and we're starting the
taxi
and i just finally look at the guy
and
i go
you know i came up with the fight one
point i literally stick my hand out
because he kept saying i was nervous and
i stick my hand right in front of his
face and i hold it level
oh that's what i did the first time yeah
i hold it level i go i'm not nervous and
he goes well anybody can do that and
that's when i was like [ __ ] this guy i'm
not talking to the guy sorry i [ __ ]
the story up then denny then he came
back got my name now he's going why are
you going to indianapolis and i finally
look at him i say listen pal
i'm drinking waters you're drinking
doers okay
there's no issue over here and then he
goes it wasn't doers what she gave me
wasn't doers really what was it some
sort of spy juice you [ __ ] jerk off
this point i want to punch him right
through his [ __ ] stupid wiry glasses
right
so
he's going like you're looking around
hostels and i said something that just
ticked him off i was just yet dude i go
i don't have to answer your questions
all right leave me alone and then he
goes uh he goes he goes he starts going
okay now i am really concerned right now
because why are you going to
indianapolis and i just look at him you
know what i start doing i start doing
like this ryan gosling
you know that little smirk that [ __ ]
mona lisa smile he has as he smirks his
way through all his [ __ ] movies i do
i go full-on ryan gosling now i'm not
talking to this guy and i just keep
looking at him
and i give him that little half a smirk
and i just shake my head that's my game
now
that's this is mike it's like if you're
going to be a dick right now with your
[ __ ] delusional authority
right that you're going to like we're in
[ __ ] guantanamo and you're going to
waterboard me huh there's no water
there's no board go [ __ ] yourself here's
my smirk and i'm just going to shake my
head at you like you're a [ __ ]
pathetic human being this is what i'm
doing right and this is the funny thing
i'm such a dick all i have to say to the
guy is i'm a comedian i'm going to do a
sold out show there and that would make
him back off but i'm a dick i'm like
[ __ ] this guy i want to see where this
is going
so now he's all [ __ ] amped up and he
starts dropping
f you know you see saying the f word
he's sitting there going
he goes you don't [ __ ] answer my
question right [ __ ] now i am going to
hit that call button we're sitting there
taxiing down the [ __ ] getting in the
line
i'm gonna [ __ ] hit this [ __ ]
button if you blah blah blah and i'm
just [ __ ] mona lisa smile smirking
just shaking my head like you were a
[ __ ] [ __ ] right
so now he's saying the f word so much
the lady who's sitting in front of me
diagonally in front right in front of
him turns around and looks at us
and now my heart's racing i'm like
where's this going this is going to be
great i am 100 [ __ ] innocent this
guy's drunk and i think he's going to
hit that button
oh i got a feeling he's going to hit
that button what's going to happen right
i want to see what the pilot looks like
let's see where the [ __ ] this is going
right so he goes if you [ __ ] you he
starts he starts bringing his hand up to
the button going i'm going to hit that
button you don't think i'll [ __ ] do
it i'll hit that button and i'm sitting
there smirking at him thinking in my
head go ahead hit the [ __ ] button
let's see what happens let's see what
happens right so finally now he wants to
hit the button and he can't [ __ ] find
it and it's in in defense of him i
couldn't find it either i was looking up
that i half wanted to hit it myself then
he finally he finally finds it and he
hits it boom
right and now i'm just like holy [ __ ]
what's gonna happen
and he's sitting there going yeah huh
you want to [ __ ] play this game how
do you want to [ __ ] play this game
and i was surprised i mean it took like
[ __ ] like 30 seconds before a flight
attendant
the one who gave him the booze which
evidently wasn't booze comes over and at
this point we're like doing that [ __ ]
where we're behind a plane we're almost
ready to take off like we're pulling up
and then stop and pulling up and
stopping as planes are taking off
so she goes yeah what's the problem over
here and he goes uh i'm not comfortable
to fly with this guy this guy he's
fidgeting he's looking around at other
[ __ ] people but blah blah blah he's
doing all this thing right and then the
stewardess looks at me and i'm just
sitting there [ __ ] my little smirk
just shaking my head and i just looking
at the dude just shaking my head like
this guy's out of his [ __ ] mind i
don't say a word and this guy goes on
and on and on about his [ __ ] psycho
babble about how the security risk
so
she goes to so she goes okay um
any other passengers have you
noticed anything she's talking to
everybody first class at this point
has anybody noticed anything
odd about this guy and the lady who was
sitting right in front of the dude
diagonally for me turns around she goes
yeah i've been listening to this guy
berating this other passenger she's on
my side and i haven't said a [ __ ]
word this is great and i'm just sitting
there smirking then the stewardess looks
of me and i shrug my shoulders like i
don't know what to tell you so finally
she said sir do you have anything to add
to this and i just said i look i'm just
a guy trying to go to indianapolis
this guy over here he starts slamming
his doors i kind of felt like a rat when
i said that i go he's slamming his doors
next thing you know he's dropping the
f-bomb to me then i'm thinking oh [ __ ] i
just said bomb
right
fortunately nothing happens so now
another [ __ ] the male stewardess
comes over right now he's going like
what's going on
and the captain of the [ __ ] now at
this point we pulled over and the plane
has stopped
250 people trying to get to indianapolis
and jerk off over here can't hold this
[ __ ] alcohol
who just watched uh person of interest
every every i guess evidently i have no
[ __ ] idea now the plane is stopped
this [ __ ] jerk-off has stopped the
plane
interrogating a goddamn comedian like
i'm in the [ __ ] taliban and like he
works for the cia right
so now we're just sitting
and the captain is up front in the plane
like
saying to the stewards is going
basically relaying do i really have to
[ __ ] come back there this is the last
flight of the night is there really a
goddamn problem and that was the vod
and they finally said to the douche sit
next to me are you gonna be okay to fly
with him and at that point it appeased
his [ __ ] ego
that he was somehow in control and he
goes like you know what okay it's fine
it's fine it'll be fine it'll be fine
so they go okay so now the plane's going
again
and now what now we [ __ ] come around
and he's sitting there [ __ ] he's in
my ear
and at this point i am lap like the
[ __ ] laugh you hear me doing the
podcast that's what i'm doing
and he's sitting there going all right
he goes you know what i'm glad i'm glad
you st i hope you [ __ ] do i hope you
[ __ ] try something hopefully [ __ ]
try something when we're up there i
really hope you [ __ ] try something
and i'm just [ __ ] like
gut-busting laughing shaking my like
what are you gonna [ __ ] do to me what
are you gonna do to me
how are you gonna punch me in the face
you [ __ ] wiry jackass
with your [ __ ] glasses on you know
that's a federal offense you're gonna go
to jail if you do that or something i
don't know what right
so i'm just sitting there [ __ ]
laughing at the guy going
i actually at one point i put my [ __ ]
little eye pillow thing on
you know like i'm going to sleep
oh i had that out too when the
stewardess was talking to me i was like
putting it on is this total mind [ __ ]
like i i don't know what this guy is i'm
just trying to go to indianapolis i'm
going to sleep
and um
so i got i got my [ __ ] eye thing on
right
as he's sitting there threatening me
just i was going total passive
aggressive it's like dude i'm so not
concerned with you i'm literally putting
a blindfold on
all right
so this [ __ ] guy
he starts going
he goes yeah he goes you think you
[ __ ] won this you think you [ __ ]
won this he goes mike you know my dad is
my dad he started saying his dad's some
major ceo in indianapolis doesn't sound
like a [ __ ] made-up story i swear to
god this is all true he goes mike my dad
is some a major ceo
in indianapolis and i'll have you
[ __ ] arrested and the lady turns
around again i would be [ __ ] arrested
the second weekend on the ground i'm
thinking like for what for what
sitting here
you [ __ ] loser learn how to hold your
alcohol
right and he starts describing the view
that i'm gonna have when i go to jail
like some [ __ ] law and order episode
oh you're gonna love it you'll be able
to see lucas oil field and blah blah
blah blah and i'm just sitting there
cracking up laughing
and then there's this pause right
and i'm thinking finally he finally shut
the [ __ ] up it's like a three four
minute pause he finally just gave up
because i wasn't giving him anything i
was just laughing and shaking my head i
was being a dick to him i was because i
was enjoying it and then there was like
a three minute pause and then all of a
sudden he just goes
why are you going to indianapolis bill
so we're like 20 minutes into the flight
and i gotta be honest with my adrenaline
was so going during all of that
because i knew i didn't do anything
wrong but i thought we were literally
going to go back and there was going to
be [ __ ] cops there and like if if
if the [ __ ] stewardess or the pilot
asked me
who i am and where i'm going i'm going
to tell them i respect your authority
you're just some j i don't you don't
have any [ __ ] authority i don't have
to answer your questions
it was probably was one of the most
fun experiences i've ever had with
another human being like when somebody
thinks that they have power and you know
they don't
and all they can do
is try just keep bluffing and raising
their voice and start cursing at you and
if you just start laughing at them the
look on their face is [ __ ] priceless
so
the last thing he said he said why are
you going to indianapolis bill right and
i [ __ ] started howling just [ __ ]
holding my stomach shaking my head
and with my [ __ ] eye pillow thing on
right
and
i know i'm gonna get a ton of [ __ ] that
i wear one of those i they're [ __ ]
underrated get the one at brookstone
where it's literally a pillow i'm
telling you you could fall asleep 12
noon facing the sun it's awesome
so anyways
like after he he asked me what you know
where you're going bill you're like
there was like a 10 minute like probably
10 minutes had gone by and i can't
[ __ ] sleep
because it's so funny to me i can't wait
to tell the story to every comic i know
i can't wait to try it on stage to see
if it's funny or whatever
uh so finally i just like gotta [ __ ] it
maybe i'll just get on my computer and i
bring up my eye pillow
and i like i gotta look at the guy
because i know he's [ __ ] staring at
me waiting for me to do something right
so i lift it up i get my [ __ ] mona
lisa smile going and i look over at the
guy and dude he is [ __ ] passed out
[Music]
he looked like he got shot he was
sitting there like his head was just
hanging straight down and anytime the
plane moved like his head was i mean he
look like he got knocked out
and for the rest of the [ __ ] flight
oh [ __ ] uh
oh what's matt damon's characters jack
ryan oh [ __ ] jack ryan over here is
just you know the sky marshall
the [ __ ] booze bag and god knows what
else he was on he was just completely
out passed out
for the rest of the [ __ ] flight and
this is how much a dick i am i was
having so much fun with this guy i start
i can't sleep
so i start slamming waters
because i want to have to get up and
take a piss just to see if this guy's
going to freak out because this security
risk is getting up and this the joke was
on me he never regained consciousness
and then i really had to take a piss but
i'm such a stubborn [ __ ] i was holding
it because i wanted to make sure he was
awake when i got up
because i was going to give him a little
smirk and then i was going to get up
see if he hit the call button again
um
but he didn't he didn't wake up till we
we hit the ground
and um
and then it's funny then he woke up and
it was like four hours later so now he
had kind of slept off whatever the [ __ ]
this guy was on
and i'm sitting there smirking waiting
for the guy to start talking i mean he
won't look at me
and i and i think at that point he kind
of [ __ ] realized that maybe he got a
little uh
a little extra little too patriotic
so
we stop
we stop at the gate and everything and
we're going to get up so i grab my [ __ ]
i get up
and i'm just kind of looking at him and
he won't look at me and then the lady
who was sitting in front of me
had this big smile on her face she goes
how you she goes how are you doing i
went good i go there i go that was an
interesting one and i said it really
loud so the guy heard and he didn't say
anything
and this is what he did to try to save
face his pillow was kind of stuck behind
was kind of stuck behind his shoulder in
like a weird place
so he was frustrated with it so he
ripped it out from behind him and kind
of threw it down on the floor went
like
trying to do some caveman grunt
to try to still have some sort of uh
i don't know what
so
so that was my flight to indianapolis
people
um you know what how far into the
[ __ ] podcast are we that was a long
that was a long [ __ ] story
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's the monday morning podcast for
monday december 16
2013 and i am recording here
on uh it's actually december 17th
uh finally back from europe
uh i apologize for the podcast being so
late but um i was in iceland and
when the [ __ ] am i ever gonna be there
again so i had to do some [ __ ] sunday
and then monday i was flying all the way
back and uh
i'm actually not that jet lagged it
worked out nice i tried and i tried to i
tried to stay up on the plane
tried to stay awake as long as i could
for most of the flight because i knew
that i was landing
um
at 7 00 p.m la time
7 25 or something so i figured if i
could just [ __ ] stay up
you know mia picks me up the airport i
just get my ass home and then if i fall
asleep
it'll be like 9 10 o'clock at night not
back on the clock and it worked out good
i woke up right
do it and i looked at the clock
and i wondered what the [ __ ] time it was
i thought it was like two something in
the morning because my clock had fell
off the bed there the digital one there
that i've had since the [ __ ] 70s
there and uh
i thought it said 2 30 in the morning
and i was like you got to be [ __ ]
kidding me i thought i i thought i did
it right
and uh then all of a sudden was six
o'clock and i realized the clock was
upside down and that was 5 30. is this
even remotely exciting i don't know if
it is or not
i'm trying to keep my voice down because
the lovely knee is still sleeping
upstairs
beautiful angel that she is and i got my
dog down here i'm psyched
gonna go hiking today get back into it i
swear to god i don't have the nerve
to step on the goddamn scale all right
and if i sound
like some skinny [ __ ]
well [ __ ] you
i'm in this business and i read your
tweets and i see when you see my face
you start calling me a fat [ __ ] all
right and i gotta tell you it hurts
sometimes
all right
no seriously no i'm vain you got to be
if you're in this business so i i think
i put on at least 10 12 pounds
i started eating like a [ __ ] goddamn
roman god
three weeks ago in italy and it never
it never stopped i kept thinking to
myself like all right when uh when the
tour starts when the tour starts i'm
gonna be [ __ ] good and we disciplined
but it just didn't work out that way it
was um
you know i this past week i i just i
think i mentioned it last week
i did a seven
country seven city run
in uh what was it six cities london
dublin
helsinki copenhagen also sweden okay six
but i did two nights in london
so it was seven nights in a row
um basically touring like a band how
they do it and i
have a whole new respect
for anybody that's touring as a band
that was hard enough to do
by myself with no equipment
i don't have to bring anything i just
[ __ ] show up
mike in a mic stand go up to the
microphone
hello and they want to you want to do a
sound check it's like well did it sound
okay when you talked into it oh yeah
yeah well there you go
what am i going to do go up there [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] you know
so
anyways uh i lost another mixer on this
[ __ ] trip
fool me once shame on you fool me twice
oh red face is a dumb [ __ ] uh there's
something about these hundred dollar
mixers believe it or not they don't have
any sort of uh
i don't know something to prevent
the surge i don't know what it is
because i had the adapter
um on the converter i should say
convert no the adapter
i forget what that [ __ ] guy in
helsinki dressed me down two years ago
once it is not a converter it is an
adapter you are not converting your
electricity you are adopting it towards
your devices yes
oh [ __ ] you hans
um
uh what's a no it's a good swedish name
i don't or a fin finished name i have no
[ __ ] idea um this podcast is going to
be all over the map
i apologize one more time for the uh the
sound quality here
um
you know my mixers [ __ ] to bed i just
discovered that so
uh but the good thing is the all things
comedy networks new studios
are up and running and um hopefully uh i
have a nice surprise guest
that i'm going to try to be interviewing
he's got a big movie coming up look at
me teasing it teasing it tickling you
with it
uh but i don't want to say he's going to
be on it because i know he's [ __ ]
busy doing press for it but uh i ran
into him
when i was in dublin which was the
greatest [ __ ] thing ever him and his
friends were [ __ ] hyped in the movie
and i was in dublin and we just went out
[ __ ] drank
and sang christmas songs it was [ __ ]
awesome
such a great tour and uh
yeah
at the risk of being corny i got to tell
you at one point
i was doing the second show in finland
and i had this
feeling when i was on stage that i was
doing exactly what the [ __ ] i'm supposed
to be doing in life
i can't explain it there's something
about making people laugh
that far away from where
uh where you live and where you speak a
language and if you're still connecting
that's pretty much
about as great an affirmation that you
know i'm really
i'm supposed to be doing it this [ __ ] is
still working i'm this far away
um
oh what a [ __ ] week
what a week i gotta tell you something
right now i did a show
in dublin ireland
and
all the crowds were great but i gotta
tell you those [ __ ] people in ireland
are the funniest that
i can't even explain
i swear well there's something about
like when i go through great britain and
ireland it's like scotland and ireland
they like the knuckleheads that i grew
up with
and when i go to london london is like
was is kind of like all the people that
i met when i went to new york that were
from boston so they they did move away
from where they were from but they still
brought that thing with them
because people in london are hilarious
but
i was doing a show dublin on monday
night
at the the vicar vicar street theater or
something
just this awesome venue by the way jim
gaffigan's going to be there if any of
you irish council listen to this you got
to go see him i was supposed to tweet
about that i'm going to do that today um
hilarious jim gaffigan's going to be
there um
and uh anyway so it was on a monday
night
and it's a really hard night to try and
sell tickets
and these people showed up in force
and i can't even tell you how
they they were [ __ ] hilarious like i
was on stage
and there was this thing i was talking
about
about people hugging their kids
and now that could put is a good thing
but if you do it too much you could
potentially make it weaker so i
mentioned
and all i've been telling this story for
like
six to eight months
and i've been saying how that you know
my mother wasn't a hugger and didn't hug
us when we were kids and people just
listen and it's just a small detail that
leads to this other part that i want to
talk about
so
i've said that line
uneventfully that's even a [ __ ] word
with with no no issue whatsoever
for like six months
now i'm in [ __ ] ireland and i just
throw that line out there like i'm not
even thinking about and say yeah i said
you know my mother didn't hug me when i
was a kid and i'm getting ready to say
the next sentence and like 15 of the
crowd goes
i'm not even doing it the way they did
it just collectively
broke my ball it was just such the
classic
[ __ ]
it was like that boston irish thing that
i grew up with distilled to its purest
form with actually real irish people
where
you almost have to be there to [ __ ]
understand what was behind it
it was like
i opened the emotional door just a crack
and automatically it's just they just
bust your balls about it like yeah you
[ __ ] you know what like you think
they i think we got hugs you freckled
[ __ ] shut the [ __ ] up and tell the joke
i can't even it just
i i've been trying to i would try to
explain it to nia she laughed but still
yeah you kind of had to be there
and then
you know so i laugh so i'm not [ __ ]
trying to get your sympathy i'm trying
to get to this next part you [ __ ]
and the whole crowd [ __ ] laughs and
then like a half hour later
what i had done when i was over there
was i bought a bunch of dvds with me
um
like just the uh
basically the dvd itself with this
little paper thing i was just handing
them out to people because i'm trying to
get them to show other people
you know when i'm out there
so i can keep coming back basically
trying to get them to uh spread the word
in my comedy and then someone's just
like why don't you just put it on
spotify you dumb [ __ ] and i'm like yeah
cause i'm old all right i feel like i
have to bring the hard copy so i tell
these [ __ ]
that i'm giving them free dvds at the
end of the show
and i'm halfway through that spiel
telling him that they're getting a free
dvd
all right
and and i'm in the middle of it and i
hear this guy in the back that crowd
goes oh [ __ ] off
i don't even think i didn't even explain
what i was doing i don't know if i had
gotten to the part where they were free
i don't know what the [ __ ] or was the
fact that i was trying to once again go
to a nice place where hey you know i
really appreciate you guys coming out
this really means a lot to me and i want
to keep coming back here because i think
you got a great
country or whatever and i just just
opened the door that much oh [ __ ] off
so i finally just looked and i went
jesus christ they're already laughing i
was like you know what i've played in 20
almost 22 years as a comedian i have
played
in front of some miserable
[ __ ] but you guys and they were
already laughing are the most miserable
[ __ ] [ __ ] i've ever been and they
loved it
absolutely loved it
and um
it killed me that i couldn't go out
drinking with the crowd because i had to
[ __ ] go uh i had an early flight of
course all the way over to helsinki
but um
and it was just kind of those moments
all the way through the tour that were
unreal like uh in helsinki i hope i'm
not boring you guys with this [ __ ] but
um in helsinki i did two shows
and the first show i went out and i just
like
felt like i couldn't get on a roll
for like a lot of the show like i'd get
laughs and then it would stop i would
get laughs and it would stop
and i was like and and it got to the
point like
there was one point
in the first show that something i said
bombed so
hard that i almost got a little
depressed and i definitely thought
because in my head some i was thinking
about
like wow i think i've reached the limits
to where my act works once i get on the
other side of the baltic sea and you
really feel that when you get on the
other side of the baltic sea you get
that feeling like
you know we're i'm not in europe anymore
you're starting to feel like i am
heading towards the soviet union
um even though you know
a good what 20 of that country is in
europe you just get this i can't explain
it you're definitely you're in eastern
europe
you're starting to get like that baltic
slavic [ __ ] vibe and and um
i had to use all these tricks that i've
learned as a comedian over the years
to basically stop the uh
i don't know what the the proverbial
comedy jet from going into a spin and
you know
crashing into the ground i just
committed harder i started um
improving aft trying to tag every joke
with something new something to get me
present
um and i was able to i still had a good
show and everything and i know they had
a good time but i was thinking in my
head like man this guy wanted me to go
to estonia
which is basically like a [ __ ]
50-minute boat ride
from uh
finland
and i was thinking like there's no
[ __ ] way i'm going there i think i've
reached the end
and then something happened during the
second show
where i was talking about getting a gun
and how i like this one gun because it
was quieter and those bigger ones are
too [ __ ] loud and if you pull the
trigger you're gonna [ __ ] destroy
your ears
and they're laughing and [ __ ] and then
as i come to the end of the joke
you know they laughed and then it was
kind of quiet and then some guy in the
crowd
yelled out you know get a silencer
and i was like well silences are illegal
where i'm at i know in jacksonville
florida they're legal because i use them
but they're illegal where i'm at they
basically say that you know i want to
murder somebody and i don't want anybody
to know
um in the next room
and then it just dawned on me and i was
like
i i just
i've been in front of really smart
crowds before and they laugh and shut up
and laugh and shut up these [ __ ] guys
the people were so smart they were
sitting there they were trying to solve
the problem of the joke
they're laughing at the joke while
coming up with solutions so i finally
said to him i said listen i was like is
this what you guys are doing
all right i'm like this isn't this isn't
a [ __ ] think tank it's just a comedy
show and then i somehow
connected with them in that moment and
then i had them
for the rest of the way and i just
started riffing on that anytime a joke
would only do okay i would just start
riffing on like the solution to whatever
the joke was and that got him back in it
and i was able to get on a uh
get on a roll with them and um
it was just kind of that all
all week dude and i was oh my god
[ __ ] helsinki i watched the sun go
down at like 3 30 in the afternoon
from my hotel oh i think by the time i
got there that's right
by the time i got to helsinki because i
had to connect in london at april
um which by the way
is um
if you ever have to go to heathrow
airport i would suggest doing two hours
of yoga before you get there it is a
unbelievable test of your patience of
your cardio
your sanity and it's [ __ ]
and i of course you know me i failed
miserably i lose my [ __ ] at lax
um
put it this way if you if you
can if you ever go to europe here's a
travel tip for you and you could avoid
connecting if you're not going to london
i would high highly recommend
not connecting
in london
because
it's not like connecting in other other
i've never had to you get off
you got to run through a whole terminal
and then wait for a bus that isn't
coming for seven minutes and then by the
time the bus comes there's so many
[ __ ] people or there's already too
many people you gotta wait for the next
bus in another seven minutes you finally
get on that [ __ ] thing
i mean it is a [ __ ] show
um
oh and by the way if anybody lights up a
cigarette it's gonna be too foggy for
anything to land so you're going to be
delayed wherever the hell you're at uh i
went through that [ __ ] thing like
three times
um
it's still still an it's an incredible
airport it's still just the sheer size
of it you have to respect but i have to
tell you give yourself plenty of time if
you can
to connect um
yeah it's a it's a it's a [ __ ]
nightmare um
i don't know what so where the hell did
i go from there
i think i went to copenhagen after that
copenhagen yep i did a show there that
was [ __ ] amazing
and uh i i got you guys got to forgive
me all the comedians that i work with
because i went night after night after
night after night and uh
you guys had some pretty crazy names
i i think this guy's name was was a
christian or something like that i can't
remember really really smart guy really
cool guy and gave me a bunch of tags
for jokes and they were actually really
funny a lot of times when somebody does
that uh
they're [ __ ] horrific but
you gotta sit there smiling like yeah
you know i'm gonna try that his were
actually great
um
uh so what else what else what else
ah [ __ ] you know what i just realized i
left it upstairs when i was in iceland
one of the two comedians that opened up
for me both of them were great i
couldn't understand what the [ __ ] they
were saying but uh one of them gave me a
book i'm gonna hit pause and i'm gonna
go upstairs and get it if you guys like
you know like those you know like those
those cartoon strips like the far side
where it's just a picture and they write
something funny
all right well if you like something
absolutely just completely
sick and twisted i just set down the
recorder hang on i'm going to look i'm
going to look it up right now i got to
find this because it's [ __ ] hilar i
mean he was killing like all the comics
i was with we were just
after we we did the show we went to
dinner and we were uh
passing the book around laughing our
asses off let's see i hate
dolphins
there it is
i hate dolphins uh
book
where the [ __ ] is it
come on man it came up i saw when it
came up hold on
i mean one one of his uh
one of his cartoons
there it is
one of his cartoons has a stick figure
they're like stick figures drawings
and he's running there's a it's a father
running after his kids with his like
acoustic guitar
over his head
and screaming uh it's your fault
i'm not a rock star and then one of the
little kids running away is going daddy
no
[Laughter]
and it's just
another one is you got two guys are
standing over
another stick figure that's laying on
the ground and it looks like it's just
blown its brains out and one of the
stick figures looks at the other and
goes
uh
something like you want to [ __ ] them
[Laughter]
it's just the darkest
sickest [ __ ] he's got two books
his other one's called something like my
pussy's hungry i don't know what it is
this guy
i don't know how to say his [ __ ] name
it's
just search uh i hate dolphins
in the comedian's name it's
who like her i don't know
hugliker
dachshund and it's spelt
h-u-g-l-e-i-k-u-r
and his last name is
d-a-g-s-s-o-n-m man this [ __ ] book is
hilarious
half the [ __ ] that's funny as you look
at it you laugh and then you hand it to
your friend and he's looking at his you
know you read what it says and you got
to kind of look at the picture and put
it together so watching
your friend taking in the joke is is
is i think it's even more enjoyable but
um
he was [ __ ] funny man he broke my
balls when he brought me up like
switched into english and uh
i forgot him what the [ __ ] he was saying
it was just great and the guy who came
on the forum was also awesome they're
just really really funny people dude
iceland
is insane
do you know they have an app over there
that basically when you meet somebody
and you want to start dating them you
just search it and you see how you're
related it'll show how you're related
i'm going to say that again they have an
app over there you meet a woman in a bar
or a woman meets a guy or whatever a
couple of twinkle toes me to each other
there
um
you [ __ ]
you just uh
there's an app that will say not if
you're related how you're related
because everybody there is [ __ ]
related
and you know it's funny they're
absolutely they're
[ __ ] great-looking people so i think
they spread it out far and wide
oh they they actually the cab drivers
over there have a joke in iceland um
and people in great britain and ireland
aren't going to like this they basically
sit because
people always talk about how beautiful
the women are and they said bill
basically the vikings
when they would conquer other people
they would just take all their good look
good-looking women and they would
take him away with them
um talk about the ultimate defeat
yeah take my farmland i don't give a
[ __ ] you take all the beautiful women
what the [ __ ] am i supposed to do
just kill me now
so they're saying that they they took
them all out of
great britain took them out of england
scotland wales and uh ireland
and they took them all to iceland and
that's why their women are so much
better looking and that there's no good
looking women in the other one which
isn't true but of course they say that
but it's [ __ ] hilarious um
and also they [ __ ] eat everything
because they live on an island
so when you go to the menu um they had
pigeon on the menu but i think that
that's their word for dove um
a buddy of mine he ordered it and i had
a piece of it tasted all right little
[ __ ] gamey and then they also had
whale and that was the only thing that i
didn't like about iceland was there's a
number of restaurants that you went into
and you could actually eat whale
which to me is like eating an elephant
you know what i mean
there's just certain animals
um
you know like look if they had like a
jackal sandwich
or a [ __ ] hyena sandwich you know
there's certain animals where you're
just like you know what you're a [ __ ]
all right
or or there's enough of you
like i'll eat venison i don't give a
[ __ ] you know there's plenty of goddamn
deer running around with their diseased
ticks
okay
[ __ ] up the front ends of a bunch of
cars i don't give a [ __ ] about that but
whales i mean they're like endangered
they must not be in danger because or at
least iceland doesn't give a [ __ ] i
don't really understand how that works
but um
you could actually eat whale
[Laughter]
[Music]
and i was just like i i that that was
the only thing that that upset me
when i was uh when i was in iceland
iceland is [ __ ] unbelievable uh you
walk around and i i recommend going in
the wintertime
don't go in the summer when there's a
bunch of people with jean shorts walking
around [ __ ] that you go in the
summertime
and
uh they got this thing the blue lagoon
spa there that you go into it's
it's [ __ ] um i can't even describe it
dude it's [ __ ] insane you're in this
[ __ ]
giant salt water like pool
that's heated
there's steam coming off it you're
surrounded by snow
and everything just looks blue
it's like you have on those uh someone
saying
uh mitch hedberg rest his soul those
blue tinted sunglasses that he used to
wear
it's like you're wearing those [ __ ]
things um
i don't it was an absolutely amazing
amazing
[ __ ] amazing uh trip i had a great
time in sweden i just want to leave any
city out here
sweden i performed in this this theater
uh
it almost looked like uh
you were in like a a circus tent but it
was a theater like you when you looked
out you felt like you was standing in
the middle but it was like because it
was like in the round but not totally it
was like a semi-circle kind of thing
um
and oslo also was a place i spent the
least amount of time but i i just had a
great time smoked a [ __ ] cuban cigar
that's another great thing cubans are
legal
and um
there are ways to get them back in the
country wink wink
um
[Laughter]
let's just say that daddy's gonna be
[ __ ] drinking a lot of scotch over
the next month
um and it's also a great thing too if
you've got buddies who smoke cigars
yeah you sneak some in for them
um or maybe you don't you allegedly do
it all right this is the monday morning
podcast um
all right let's get into the advertising
for this week
all right the man great system man great
everybody
this season think the man great what is
the man great you asked or maybe you
didn't but you're happy that i just
asked that question for you they are 100
percent made in america america cast
iron grilling grates that are
revolutionizing the way people grill
named one of 2012's best grilling
accessories by men's health magazine man
greats are the perfect gift this holiday
season click on the man
click on the man great banner
at billboard.com for their 1999 holiday
special remember each monday morning
podcast order comes with a heavy duty
grilling brush again that's the man
great grill enhancement system ordered
today at billboard.com somebody was
bitching about the shipping on these
things going you know it's actually not
19.99 it's more like 35 bucks it's like
dude it's a hundred percent cast iron
grilling grates
that's gonna make your dad or your
brother whoever else is into grilling
make their steaks taste [ __ ]
delicious forever
okay you can't kick in an extra 15 bucks
to ship the [ __ ] thing and you get a
grilling brush
jesus christ
you know what i don't know what it is in
the chinese new year but i think this
year this was the year with a whiny [ __ ]
um
all right all right what do we got here
dollar shave club everyone for a couple
of bucks a month dollarshaveclub.com
delivers amazing quality razors right to
your door not only does it save you a
ton of cash it saves you from trudging
to the drugstore for a pack of blades
um i always tell you guys i always get
stuck behind either the person coming in
to write you know 12 cases of beer or i
get stuck behind the old lady
an old guy that you know want to get ice
cream and develop film and all that crap
right they got 20 registers and only one
is open
you know because they're trying to
exploit new revenue streams you know the
deal um
you don't have to deal with that because
now with dollar shave club for a couple
of bucks a month amazing quality razor
blades are delivered right to your damn
door that's right no more wasting time
and no more getting hit up for like 20
bucks every time you buy razors
everybody here is getting their dollar
shave club blades and you should too and
here's a genius idea try replacing your
old shaving cream with dr cava's easy
shave butter
from dollar shave club dot com trust me
your face will thank you later um don't
waste time at the drugstore behind the
lady paying in pennies go to
dollarshaveclub.com forward slash bur or
go to billboard.com and click on the
dollar shave club banner uh keep your
stress level low and your bank account
balance high shave time shave money go
to dollarshaveclub.com forward slash bur
um
what do we got there left
we got two more left all right we'll do
some more podcasting and then i'll get
back to that
so um
is there anything else i can tell you
guys
about um
oh here's a good one for jet lag i like
to uh fly at night
leave wherever you're going
like if you're flying east to west if
you fly around three four in the
afternoon
that's also the sweet spot at the
airport by the way because then you
coming around two
one two o'clock in the afternoon and for
the most part people
wherever they're staying they either
want to get the [ __ ] out of there or
they want to try to stretch in another
day so they either get you know
fly between
six in the morning to 10
or they start leaving around you know
five
or maybe seven because they want to skip
the rush hour traffic so
that's a good time to go and
you're basically you're flying in
tonight
so it's easy to go to sleep you can get
eight hours you're definitely be
jet-lagged when you get to europe but
coming back
um
when did i leave
oh you know what sucked the only sucked
when i was coming back was i was in
iceland so i'm halfway across the
atlantic the atlantic ocean
and but it was like a zillion dollars
and way more miles than i had
to try to get a nice business class seat
um
straight to la so i had to fly back to
[ __ ] april
connected in april
and um
i was getting off icelandic air and
switching to virgin air
so i checked my bag and i had to [ __ ]
go to baggage claim i had to go through
customs
go down and get the [ __ ] bag
and then do the bus thing to this thing
to that thing with the [ __ ] bag and
dude you want to hear about a whiny [ __ ]
cursing up a [ __ ] storm
and then i ended up having plenty of
time
i had plenty of time i ended up drinking
a couple of scotches there and i talked
to some woman who was from poland and i
was saying you know i had some people
come out to my shows in poland
in copenhagen i'd love to go there and
she's like where do you want to go and i
was like warsaw and she just shook her
head she said hey you know i go there
it's too uh
too commercial and she [ __ ] broke
down all the poland for me so i'm
telling you guys you got to do it you
got to do it if you got the time or
whatever or make time [ __ ] that even if
you got kids [ __ ] it
all right [ __ ] getting that second flat
screen tv [ __ ] that college education
it's gonna be there
okay they're not gonna get a college
education because you spent [ __ ]
seven days
in europe one [ __ ] time
one time you spent it there and you
dropped them off with with the parents
to watch them that's great they're gonna
get closer to your grandparents
you know
your parents will get to spend time with
your kids and you'll get to go over
there
get to see the world from a different
perspective you gotta [ __ ] do it uh
highly recommend it you can do it on the
[ __ ] cheap you really can't just get
your [ __ ] asses over there and have
yourself a salmon sandwich all right
um
i really hope as many people you know
[ __ ] go you know what's great and
i've been reading when i was in scotland
so i told you somebody gave me this book
david lee roth's book that came out in
the late 90s crazy from the heat and i
got to tell you this is a [ __ ] killer
book man
what i love about it is he's not dishing
a bunch of dirt about van halen and
going eddie's a [ __ ] and michael anthony
and alex and all that he definitely
takes a shot here or there but he went
through a real painful [ __ ] thing
with the ending of that god knows they
trashed him enough but a lot of it is
he's describing what it's like to be on
the road
and um right now he's talking about the
extensive travel that he's done
talking about he ended a tour in 83 with
van halen in argentina
so he's with his security guy big ed
uh not to be confused with eddie van
gaal this is a different guy big head
and he's like well you know we kind of
have to go past
the uh the amazon
to get back to uh la why don't we go
there
and big ed was like oh yeah i've always
wanted to go to africa and david lee's
just like all right close enough
whatever
so they he talks about
just like
dropping a boat into the amazon river
and going [ __ ]
down the river up the river whatever
he's doing getting dysentery feeling
like he's gonna die having 12 second
convulsions
um this is a [ __ ] rock star who the
hell does this [ __ ] man it's really
really amazing
and uh when i put down the book this
morning he was about ready to go up uh
he was in the himalayas
up going through the valley approaching
mount everest
um
he has this great theory of like you
know because he's he's a night guy that
he's seen all these great cities
he always brings his bicycle on tour and
he rides a bike through the city at
night
and he said you really get to see the
city and feel the spirits of the city
and i was thinking [ __ ] man maybe i told
you this last week because i kind of had
that moment when i was sitting there
outside the vatican
you gotta [ __ ] do it you gotta
[ __ ] do it okay and if some [ __ ]
like me
who [ __ ] flunked
didn't flunk everything in high school
but i swear to god i got c's d's and e's
they weren't called f's where i was from
uh it was a [ __ ]
i told you this this before when i was a
freshman in high school i was going to
go to notre dame and become a lawyer and
by the time i was a sophomore i was like
well maybe i'll get into roofic that's
how bad i did
um
just completely [ __ ] the bad the bed
like [ __ ]
fumble the punt whatever the [ __ ] you
want to call it um
yeah it was awful so uh so anyways
that's that's my travel talk
all right that gives all the people who
hate sports
when i talk about uh when i talk about
sports too much on the podcast i gave
you a break and uh i have no [ __ ]
idea
what is going on in any sport other than
hockey because i got the bruins app on
my phone
and uh i know they had a great west
coast trip got their asses kicked to him
uh
hand it to him her ass is kicked or ass
is handed to him or asked his kick to
him
is that a new one
i got my ass kicked to me it's like they
removed your ass and as you then they
walked across the street and then punted
your ass back over to you because they
felt so bad about the beatdown there you
go there's a new one um by the vancouver
canucks so it's funny they're all giving
me [ __ ] on twitter
um doing that stupid this this this
beating the bruins six to one priceless
so
i don't know why you would say that to
me i'm like well uh
losing the first two games in the finals
and coming back to win five out of the
next six
or five what wait a minute that doesn't
make sense does it
four in the next five jesus christ bill
there's my high school math again losing
the first two and then coming back to
win
for the last five and game seven in your
[ __ ] building i think that's a little
bit better to win a stanley cup all
right so congratulations on your regular
season win and all you [ __ ] out there
who are giving me [ __ ] because the
patriots lost to the dolphins
all you fantasy football playing
[ __ ] morons
okay who actually think that brady's
lost a step and they're so [ __ ]
dumb
when it comes to watching sports and
analyzing what the [ __ ] going on can
you get your nose half an inch away from
the paper looking at numbers
uh you better wake the [ __ ] up because
there's only like another week i guess
of of regular season football tom brady
is in the middle of one of his greatest
seasons he's ever had the fact that they
have the record that they do
with uh the level of injuries and the
[ __ ] that those people we lost to free
agency it's been [ __ ] unreal
like somebody wrote me on twitter like
really how the [ __ ] do you lose to the
dolphins it's like well first of all
it's easy you score less points than
they do and second of all whenever you
play a division rival they see you twice
a year every year they know who you are
they know what the [ __ ] you do
if you're a gambler if you ever want to
bet on an upset
i would definitely say
bet that the division rival especially
if they lost the first time is at least
going to cover if not [ __ ] beat them
it happens all the time i don't know
what sport you're [ __ ] watching
and uh we have catastrophic [ __ ]
injuries on defense i'm not making i
actually i am making excuses but like
um
what i'm really saying is that if i was
in the states and i was watching the
patriots versus the dolphins there's no
[ __ ] way that i would just be like oh
there's no way we're not going to win
this game
um so anyways that's all i know about
what's going on in football
um i've st i completely missed the
cleveland browns game i guess where the
patriots got
all those new age calls
where it doesn't seem like it's football
anymore you know what i mean um
so anyways uh
let's get on to some
let's get on some oh oh and i got a new
tv show whenever i go overseas and i'm
jet lagged i always put on netflix and i
get into something else
or i buy a box set i got into the
killing
i don't know if anybody's watching that
but i am three episodes in and i'm
watching every second of this series
phenomenal
series definitely not for the
emotionally light
uh if you don't want
to deal with something that's it's
pretty [ __ ] heavy and they do not
pull any punches they take they walk you
right through it
where you feel like you're living
living it it's it's uh amazing [ __ ]
uh
amazing show so far phenomenal which
shot the acting all that type of [ __ ]
and i'm looking at like [ __ ] i'd love to
be on a show like this so who knows i'm
gonna bug my agent today hey can i uh
can i play a body or something on that
show i'd love to be on it um
anyways um i want to thank everybody for
watching the podcast t-shirts
uh
my t-shirt uh slash podcast guy andrew
themeless
stand up extraordinaire who will also be
at that new year's eve show at the
wilton out here in los angeles
if you want to see the crew and
knuckleheads
that gets [ __ ] hammered every year
out on the golf course they're going to
the rose bowl it's andrew demelis
joe bartnick
jay lawhead jason lahat and myself
and there are very limited tickets left
so um
if you need a uh if your plans fell
through come on down we'll make you
laugh
and uh i don't know i think we're gonna
stick around do a countdown and all that
we're gonna be boozing it up
love to see you guys down there but um
anyways he was mentioning that i believe
the podcast t-shirts
are sold out at this point for the most
part except for some of the bigger sizes
i think
and if you have any problem with your
order
the email to check in
is uh billboardmerch gmail.com
all lowercase billberrymerch merch
gmail.com uh we take pride in getting
this stuff out to you i think andrew's
done a great job
really really killed it
but let us know if you're having any
problem
um
you know we are human beings we do [ __ ]
up but we don't want to [ __ ] you over so
let us know if there's a problem as soon
as possible and we'll make it right okay
all right here we go on the questions
and the lettuce this week
finland show hey bill love your show in
helsinki well thank you
um
i definitely pay to see you again i
don't know if it was just me there were
a few moments where i felt you worried
about offending the audience or
something that's extremely hard to do
yeah see you probably there at the first
show i was
feeling you guys out man and i think i
also had that long flight from dublin
where i got
i got delayed at aphro
connected in april
um
and i literally landed went right to the
show so i might have been just a tad off
he said that's extremely hard to do
uh here so next time don't worry about
any
any of that the less you pull punches
the more you're gonna get out of the
audience in finland
oh that's awesome man thank you that
thank you for uh reading from your
playbook well i think i figured you guys
out as i just mentioned the story
uh on the story on the podcast telling
that story
um anyway because ps my ex-girlfriend
was a ginger she was a real [ __ ]
i didn't even know she was a ginger
until i took her pants off
oh [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] funny um
yeah no you know what it was was i came
out and i it's just like you guys are
really [ __ ] like sorry any comic is
going to play
finland over there this i mean i can't
say this is just my experience because
it was my [ __ ] jet lag my act that i
was doing and whatever the [ __ ] was
going on with me chemically
so i can't say this is gonna happen but
uh they're a [ __ ] great crowd
and now
this guy's saying that you can't offend
them you know what's great when you go
through all of those um
i basically did all of uh
the nordic countries
and i've told you guys this before
scandinavia consists of norway
uh sweden and denmark
and
those three countries
that's scandinavia but within them
scandinavia is part of the nordic
countries
and that includes all of scandinavia the
three i just mentioned and then finland
iceland
and i think they're called the feral
islands that's the only place i didn't
go the feral islands which are like
northwest
of uh scotland
um
but what's great when you go through all
of that is for the most part
it's predominantly lutheran lutheran or
lutheran i don't know how to say
properly but they and they basically
believe
that when you die you're dead you just
go into the ground
and it's just like
and i say well don't you wonder like can
you wrap your head around not existing
they're like yeah it's just like
before you were born you don't remember
that it's the same thing
and
because of that
they're really [ __ ] logical
um if that makes sense if there's any
comedian listen to this i would
basically describe but you ever do a
college gig and you think you're
bombing but then you realize oh wait
these this is a really smart school
and they just laugh in a different way
that's basically what uh helsinki was
like so uh thanks for the heads up i i
did have a great time
um and i hope those people on the first
show had a good time too i was you know
i don't want to let people down you know
i'll make sure i give him the whole
[ __ ] thing and i tell i made a rule
that i wasn't going to [ __ ] at all on
this tour because i knew it was going to
be brutal going from place to place to
place to place every day [ __ ] waking
up going to the airport landing and then
trying to figure out how [ __ ] making my
jokes work
um so because i made the rule that i
wasn't gonna [ __ ] i only bitched like
30 times as opposed to like
three thousand
although if you counted each individual
[ __ ] going through eighth row
connecting in april
um that i probably bitched like 700
times but i was compartmentalized that's
a word
to uh
heathrow airport um
for the most part
all right hey bill love from morocco
um bill before i start i just want to
let you know that my sister
and i attended your show in london last
week uh
you did a great job blah blah blah blah
uh you had the whole crowd and
but enough with the ass kicking okay
here's a little conspiracy theory for
you at the end of the show
we had a little argument about your
ghost segment
yeah i don't believe in ghosts he said
which was [ __ ] hilarious to go
through a place that doesn't believe
that you go anywhere when you die you
know when i was going through
scandinavia in the nordic countries
because i would i'd be like usually when
i say there's no ghosts i don't believe
in ghosts there's someone in the crowd
that's like ah you know i believe in
ghosts yeah absolutely
and they they were just sitting there in
those other countries just like yeah
yeah why the [ __ ] would you believe in
ghosts that's stupid
so he goes he goes remember when the
your bottle fell off the stool
and the water spilled on stage yeah i
did this whole segment about how i don't
believe in ghosts and i remember when i
went to set down
my water bottle for some reason the
cushion on the seat it was sort of doing
like the leaning tower of pisa thing
so anyways i finished the ghost bit
and i was into some other jokes
and all of a sudden it looks like the
bottle tipped over by itself one of
those great stand-up moments where you
can't plan it it tipped over itself
and then uh and i didn't realize that
the crowd is reacting and it was like a
full bottle so it's just pouring out
um got all over the stage and everything
and then of course i riffed that it was
actually a ghost and that is trying to
electrocute me and all that type of [ __ ]
and um
and it worked great but anyways he said
my sister think
thinks
that was part of your act
the ghost thing and there was no way you
could be that good at improv i better 50
pounds that it wasn't planned either way
it was beautifully done do you mind
settling this for us yeah no it was not
planned
do you realize how cheesy that would be
if you planned that
you know so not to kill
the whole improv thing it's really not
that difficult to come up with some
funny [ __ ] when water spills by itself
after you just did a ghost thing
um
it isn't
you know and
you don't realize how many times i mean
you [ __ ] improv everybody's improving
when you walk and you're having a
conversation
you're totally in the moment with
somebody and you're you're
without realizing it because you
understand language you're listening and
translating and you're also which is
reminding you some other [ __ ] that
you're thinking about that adds to where
the conversation goes
um
what it is so everybody can do that it's
just when you get on stage it's it's
you're you're going on stage starting
your career and you're dealing with
stage fright
and forcing yourself to do this thing
that scares the [ __ ] out of you which
causes you to think which shuts down all
of your improbabilities but over the
years as you do it
you get more and more comfortable and
you become as comfortable on stage as
you are off stage and then once again
you tap back into that power of
improving that everyone in the crowd is
already doing
um
but for you but it's just not defined as
it so that's that's basically what it is
so no that was not
that was a uh
that was not planned um
i actually had another great one that i
i was doing uh another great moment i
should say it's not gonna pat myself in
the back i had another great uh moment
of
improv when i took the mic stand and
pretended it was a skinny woman
um and just yelled eat something for an
hour no um i was in iceland when i
walked on stage they had a [ __ ] giant
christmas tree just to the right of the
stage all lit up looking beautifully
but i i so i went into this stupid thing
where i was acting like
it was stealing focus
and i was being in diva and i refused to
tell any more jokes
until somebody [ __ ] when you
reykavik sons of [ __ ] comes up here
and takes this goddamn tree down and i
went on this whole long thing
and it just happened right at the
beginning of the show i just saw it and
i just
i don't know
i just [ __ ] started talking about it
and it killed and they loved it and then
later on in the act
i apologize to the tree
like it was you know like i was in some
abusive relationship with it like hey
you know i'm
listen i'm sorry about what i said
earlier you know
you know i feel about you and blah blah
and just kind of went on this thing like
that's the most fun thing as a comedian
was when you get comfortable enough to
do that [ __ ] because
i'm not gonna lie to you you get sick of
telling your jokes
um but anyways he finishes off he says
also i've been introducing you to my
moroccan friends over the years
and as soon as i can get 10 000 people
to like you i'll email you so that you
can uh
so you can come visit um
thanks and go [ __ ] yourself well you
know what send a [ __ ] email
to uh billboard merch at gmail.com and
andrew will hopefully get back to me
maybe uh
i can figure out some [ __ ] uh i'll
send you some promotional a promotional
package or some [ __ ] i'll send some of
my
my wares over there
and uh the only thing you got to do is
hand them out to your friends okay
that's it all right
um
where the [ __ ] am i
oh there's the ending thanks and go [ __ ]
yourself all right you go [ __ ] yourself
too
all right underage girl equation
all right let's hope this doesn't get
creepy again uh bill long time fan
listener caught a few shows glad you're
kicking ass thank you uh here's the
important part here's the important part
yeah [ __ ] my career exactly uh to
calculate acceptable age differences
between partners here's my rule of thumb
all right for those of you who are just
new to the podcast or haven't listened
in the past couple of weeks because you
have a life
um
lately i don't lately i don't know
what's been going on but people have
been sending me these [ __ ] emails
and uh
it's somehow it's like yeah you know 27
my girlfriend's 19 we've been dating for
six years and uh it's like wait a minute
wait what the [ __ ]
you know it gets weird so this is what
he's referring to
he goes here's the important part to
calculate acceptable age differences
between partners
here is my rule of thumb
half your age plus seven that's it
works for everyone pretty much if you're
22 half your age is 11
plus 7 equals 18.
um dude i got to say 22 to 18 that is
that's
still a huge age different but but it is
legal
it is legal
i don't know how you don't feel like
[ __ ]
matthew mcconaughey and dazed and
confused with that one dude because
you're literally talking like
you know
you got a mustache by 22. come on man
she's 18
finishing up high school
and you've just wrapped college that's a
huge difference but you know 26 to 22 is
not a big deal
um
anyways but i i like i like what you're
saying he said 18 is you cut off
so yeah that does make sense it is legal
he goes if you're 80 half your age is 40
plus seven is 47. boom there it is again
reasonable differences regardless of age
yeah it depends on who you are in that
one i think i would rather be the 80
year old i feel like i'm stealing money
at that point but i like what you you
come where you're coming from here he
goes i'm not saying there aren't
uh there aren't anomalies out there for
every situation but for a simple guide
to not being a pervy [ __ ] bag stick with
the half plus seven rule
uh been meaning to share this with you
for a while but seeing as every week we
seem to have a new douchebag trying to
justify his perversion well it's time
yeah thank you all right there you go
people
half your age plus seven if it doesn't
[ __ ] work out well half your age plus
seven and she's still 18 or older
right
because if you're 18 half your age
is 9 plus 7 is 16
i mean you're in trouble there that
statutory rape
that still kind of works out good i'm
16.
half my age is eight plus seven is
fifteen that [ __ ] works
you're twelve half your age is six plus
seven she's thirteen you're [ __ ]
slaying it i love this theory
i love this [ __ ] theory god damn it
that works this son of a [ __ ]
he's like matt damon in that [ __ ] uh
where he's got the mop and he's good at
math
one flew over the cuckoo's nest dazed
and confused [ __ ] uh i got to see
about a girl what the [ __ ] is it called
goodwill hunting
there you go i shook it loose
um oh you know what i watched i watched
a couple of movies i watched all boston
guy movies mark wahlberg
i watched the one with tim and the rock
i did
fall asleep because i was trying to stay
awake that has nothing to do with the
movie i loved any movie about [ __ ]
weightlifting it's got mark wahlberg in
it right that takes me back to the 80s
when nobody did squats and everybody
just kept [ __ ] you know doing upper
body
upper body
uh i got a friend of my comedian uh in
boston wayne previtt used to always talk
about that how back in the day nobody
used to [ __ ] do squats and then you
just put on your puffy pants
you see cavalry cheese over there to try
to make it look like you had thighs
vinnie age um
so anyways i watched that one uh
whatever that movie was called i never
remember the names then i watched the uh
the matt damon movie
where he's in the future and they put
that thing and that bionic [ __ ] around
them [ __ ] great movie
just [ __ ] that that's a great [ __ ]
movie i i stand by both of those
and
also
i watched a movie called uh called
drinking buddies
that um
jesus christ i never watched a movie it
was about dating and that type of thing
i never watched a movie where i felt
like uh
i was kind of every guy in the movie
you know what i mean
like the guy sneaking around [ __ ]
around the guy the sap
taking back the girl that's [ __ ]
around
the guy wants to commit but can't the
guy who's [ __ ] not committing the
whole goddamn thing
um
it was a really i really enjoyed that
movie and it had uh
who's it got in it olivia wilde uh
jake johnson who i [ __ ] worked with
on um
oh jesus christ new girl
i swear to god man i can i can somebody
send me some fish pills whatever the
[ __ ] you're supposed to take i can't
remember anything
uh
really enjoyable movie
um
so whatever there's my movie plugs for
this week
what else do i got here uh let's do some
advertising here um hulu plus everybody
you probably tried hulu.com with hulu
plus you can watch your favorite shows
anytime anywhere dude i'm telling you
this right here is the future
uh hulu plus lets you watch thousands of
hit tv shows and a selection of claimed
movies on your television or on the go
with your smartphone or tablet and it
streams in hd every time for the best
viewing experience with hulu plus you
can watch your favorite current tv shows
like saturday night live community and
family guy you can also check out
exclusive content including hulu
originals like the awesome starring snl
seth meyers who by the way has his own
talk show coming out the beginning of
the new year look for that and moonboy
starring chris o'dowd from bridesmaids
hulu plus also offers a great selection
of acclaimed films for only 7.99 a month
you can stream as many tv shows and
movies as you want wherever you want
this really is the future people this is
how you're going to watch tv
um right now you can try hulu plus for
free for two weeks when you go to hulu
plus dot com slash bill that's first
that's a special offer for my listeners
uh make sure you use huluplus.com
bill um so you get your extended free
trial and that they know that everybody
over here sent you go to huluplus.com
bill now or click on the hulu plus
banner on the podcast page at
billboard.com um
that is the future my friends especially
if you travel
i don't know you're in college you don't
get you're not gonna be around a tv or
over a friend's house you're going home
for the [ __ ] holidays it's just it's
the greatest thing ever um and last
but not least everybody um my one is at
least we got three more here uh two more
sorry e-voice the holidays are coming
and as a business owner you know what
that means crickets face it um leading
up to the holidays is the calm before
the storm now is the time to do
something that will dramatically help
your 2014 e-voice e-voice is the simple
technology that helps you make more
money with e-voices toll-free or local
numbers call routing tools and a
professional dial by name directory your
business will look like a million bucks
and with e-voice if you if you can't
take a call they will transcribe the
voicemail and email it to you you'll
never get caught off guard again e-voice
has been helping
companies save thousands of dollars
every month making them more efficient
and more productive there's no quicker
or easier way to transfer your business
for 2014 and with e-voice you can try it
before you buy it
jesus christ can these guys make it any
easier right now you can you can
slow it down bill right now you can get
a 30-day trial
to e-voice when you go to e-voice.com
billburr or go to billboard.com and
click on the e-voice banner that's on
the podcast page by the way uh that's
evoice dot com slash billboard or
billboard.com and click on the e-voice
banner uh now's the time to take charge
of your business and prepare for prepare
for a productive 2014. once again go to
evoice.com bill burr or go to
billboard.com click on the podcast page
and uh click on the evoice banner for
your free 30-day trial that's evoice.com
jesus christ they got it all right
stamps.com everybody the last one here
um one great resolution you can make for
the new year maximize every minute and
every dollar for your small business i
know an easy way to do that with
stamps.com think about how much time you
wasted going to the post office driving
there finding parking stamps dot com is
a the better way to get postage
just use what you already have your
computer and printer to get official us
postage for any letter or package then
the mailman comes and picks it up
doesn't get any more simple than that
with stamps.com everything you could do
with the post office you can do right
from your desk whenever the hell you
want to do it and at a fraction of the
cost
of one of those expensive postage meters
i've been using stamps.com for months
um
actually no for like a year and a half
it's about as convenient as it can get
and i got to tell you with all this
merchandise you know the t-shirts and
that type of thing would be an absolute
nightmare to have to go to the post
office so anyways right now use my last
name bur
to get this special offer no risk trial
plus 110 bonus offer that includes a
digital scale and up to 55 dollars free
postage don't wait go to stamps.com
before you do anything else click on the
microphone at the top of the home page
and type in bur b-u-r-r that stamps dot
com enter bur
and there you go that is your ad
virtuous advertisements
for the week your adverts
as they say over there in england i
guess they say that
um
what are we doing here let's go to the
next one sparkling water
the next email here
uh sparkling [ __ ] water
bill pickles
oh i get it dill tickles bill uh dill
dill tickles dill pickles bill pickles i
get it all right there's a new one there
is a new one my friends
he said i saw in one of your tweets that
you were upset about accidentally
ordering sparkling water yeah that
happened to me when i was in i was in
london
uh
going to april connecting in april um
you know they they put it in the clear
bottle it looks just like water
and you know when you're in a different
country like [ __ ] gets hard
[ __ ] you just take for [ __ ] grant
like that i never accidentally i very
rarely do i accidentally grab sparkling
water
when i'm uh in the states here because i
know
poland spraying i know i know what the
[ __ ] bottled water the still [ __ ] looks
like
but uh that is the most amazing thing
when you when you travel abroad is this
part of your brain you have to use that
you never use
like i never realized how much [ __ ] i
recognize just out of color
um
and then all of a sudden you go overseas
and you just like all right is that a
taxi or a police car
you know does is that a pharmacy or are
they selling clothes and i'm not even
joking because
the way that some of the stores look
over over uh overseas they they
their style that they'll do the store in
that's their style for a [ __ ]
pharmacy although pharmacies are pretty
easy over there because they have a they
have a neon green like cross it's really
easy to find so that's probably a bad
one but anyways yes so anyways he goes i
hope you come around on this score it's
never too late to change
um
oh i think this guy's just telling me
that he likes sparkling water well jesus
christ bill why don't you just read the
[ __ ] thing so we can all find out all
right he said you know men of great
character and sophistication have long
been enjoying sparkling water oh jesus
christ well let me go dress up for this
[ __ ] email
this guy's sitting there with his legs
cross wearing it was an ascot is that
how he said he says it's a satisfying
bevy
that you can drink endless quantities
endless quantities of while you battle
the temptations of various other
addictions
like when you're off the bottle i highly
recommend reaching for a bottle of sand
pellegrino it has a punch that plain
water or fruity juice just can't give
you it's like hard alcohol in the sense
that it's an acquired taste
uh on top of the hard alcohol a nice
i can't i don't know how that is
gerald steiner
mixes wonderfully with alcohols
of all kinds my preference being vodka
and whiskey
it's a much better mix than fruity
juices and sodas and all that other
uh
[ __ ] [ __ ] just cuts a bit
it's like water waters ass big brother
i remember you saying that you don't
drink coffee you're saying you've missed
out on all that coffee house [ __ ] over
the years so this is one
pairing that i probably can sell you on
um
what
so this is one pairing that i probably
can't sell you on but an espresso drink
no sugar with the perrier to hydrate you
[ __ ] delightful or i know you've been
to italy an anti-pastel plate with a
glass of wine and a glass of sparkling
water
uh bueno
i hope i said that right i don't know i
wanna b-u-o-n-o
uh love the stand-up love the podcast
as a working poor type nine to five or
the podcast makes monday almost bearable
look at you getting all [ __ ]
he goes waiting for the canadians hockey
cities dates here in montreal not a habs
fan a centers fan all right um
yeah dude i don't like drinking
carbonated [ __ ] i think it makes you
bloated it makes you fat for no [ __ ]
reason and you should be drinking water
uh i'm not into this [ __ ] and when i'm
off the bottle i just get off the bottle
totally and i drink water and then i
look down and my stomach getting flatter
every day and i [ __ ] enjoy it but uh
yeah i'm just not a uh
i'm not a sparkling water guy i'm just
not i don't like this [ __ ] uh
if i'm gonna drink something carbonated
i'll have
a soda
or a pot or a pop as they say in the
midwest
and what do i like i like
the mexican coca-cola that has the real
sugar and i like um
i like orange soda but only if that has
the good sugar too
um
all right dude the jetlags hit me here
i'm just [ __ ] talking about what
kinds of soda i [ __ ] like
um all right opposite of anorexia yeah
speaking of what i mentioned earlier
that i gained some weight here opposite
of anorexia
uh hey there bill i think i might have
the opposite of anorexia because when i
look in the mirror i see a skinny guy
while i have trained with push-ups and
weights and gain like 10 pounds
right now i am 18 years old 62 and 187
pounds which should be normal also when
i look at my classmates classmates i
seem bigger
and
more muscular but when i'm home and
staring in the mirror i just seem skinny
anyways love your podcasts greetings
from holland yeah dude um
opposite of anorexia i don't know what
that means yeah but you got some sort of
body issue dude if you're 62 187 yeah
you look you look fine and you're also
18 years old you're gonna fill out
um
my suggestion is to look into the mirror
and override those negative thoughts and
think something positive
and i gotta tell you dude when you get
older
okay and you got to go to the gym for
two [ __ ] weeks to get yourself
looking halfway decent and then you have
one french fry and it negates all two
weeks that you did you're gonna [ __ ]
look back and go god remember when i was
six two and i was 187 pounds for the
love of god enjoy this period in your
life as much as you can because there's
no way to enjoy it fully the way some
old bastard like me could
um
because i know what it's like now to
[ __ ]
do all the work i did and then go away
for a couple of [ __ ] weeks and come
back and look like oh my god dude i
[ __ ] pat on a pullover sweater the
last [ __ ] night and i took a picture
with somebody and i was sucking in my
gut and i still look like a [ __ ] ah
i knew it somebody took a picture of me
when i was in iceland and i saw him i'm
getting my fat head back again it killed
me so dude um
you're killing it you're six two you're
187 pounds you're 18 years old he got
your whole life ahead of you you should
just be focusing on finding [ __ ]
places to go have a good time
all right go walk up chat up the most
beautiful women you can find
and just have a great [ __ ] time all
right
quit looking in the mirror thinking
you're some [ __ ] skinny loser you're
not all right you're a goddamn [ __ ]
rocks you're the rock star
are you of your life right now all right
and then don't use this as some negative
thing like it's all downhill from here
stop being a [ __ ] [ __ ] go out and
enjoy your goddamn life you look great
you son of a [ __ ] go [ __ ] yourself all
right accidentally racist
um hey bill i was waiting in line
uh for the water fountain at my gym with
a buddy in this african-american guy was
taking forever to fill up his
gallon-sized water bottle don't you
[ __ ] hate people who do that at the
gym
cheap cheap [ __ ] i get that
you're doing it i get it but if you see
somebody behind you you got a gallon
water baller maybe it was just a bigger
one
you you know what you be a good [ __ ]
turn around and be like are you just
getting a drink yeah let me step aside
you know be a [ __ ] [ __ ]
you know what that's like that's like
people who stand in the middle of
sidewalks with four other friends and
have conversations and the whole world
has to walk around them or they do it in
the airport if you're stopping and you
you're gonna make your flight are you
trying to figure out where the [ __ ]
you're supposed to be
go grab the wall get over to the [ __ ]
wall let people you know if your car
[ __ ] breaks down
if it's safe to do it [ __ ] push it to
the side of the road you dumb [ __ ]
all right sorry anyways he goes i was
getting impatient as you should have he
goes i remember that the gym recently
got rid of a separate fountain
with a big nozzle so you could fill up a
water bottle quicker so i remarked to my
buddy
didn't they used to have separate
fountains for these people
oh [ __ ]
oh no he goes before my buddy can
respond the african-american guy turns
around
and says excuse me
cue foot and mouth
so what's the best accidentally racist
story you've got
uh wait a minute dude yeah i hope you
explain that to him
uh you know what i have to think
accidentally right i know i've done that
i know i've done that wait how did i do
that
i remember when i was in dc i just made
a joke and the guy didn't find it funny
and then i felt like a [ __ ] [ __ ]
um it was right after obama got elected
i was in dc and i was [ __ ] hammered
and i was coming back to this hotel with
joe derosa
and uh
the security guy who was black
african-americans said something to me
and as a joke
i go oh what the president is black now
so well and i'm hammered and i thought
he was going to laugh and he stared at
me like oh my like this is a white
person who actually thinks this [ __ ]
and i was like i was just [ __ ] around
joe's like dragging me away
like i went like it was a joke that
would have worked if i was sober and i
was in a comedy club and i'd set it up
right but i didn't
oh and i kind of [ __ ] knew the guy
but i didn't know the guy it was three
in the morning i was drunk and it like
dude it was [ __ ] horrific and i and
it kills me that i wasn't able to
explain myself because i guarantee that
that guy still [ __ ]
at least told that story for two weeks
so um
i don't know that's actually a good
topic if anybody else has accidentally
racist
[ __ ] oh my god that's too that's like
i would submit that to [ __ ] larry
david doesn't that seem like an episode
of his show
you know
it happened in the beginning like you
know just whining that he has to go to
the gym and all that [ __ ] [ __ ] moaning
and complaining he sees the guy with the
water bottle
and then the misdirection is
he talks about how cheap these people
are and he actually defends the gym for
all the water that they're using
um
and then when he shows up it's gone and
then he stands behind i mean the whole
[ __ ] thing is right there
and you put that music underneath it you
got yourself an episode
all right ski lodges
hey there billy bunny hill
uh what's your take
uh what's your take a good weekend
come on people you know i i can't read
out loud can you can you at least help
me by at least
trying to put all the words from the
sentence in the [ __ ] email
what's your take i'm gonna guess on a
good weekend
of banging snow bunnies and drinking hot
chocolate
what's my take on it what that sounds
like one of those
[ __ ] titty movies i watched when i
first got cable what what
what take what i have on other than
that's [ __ ] awesome he goes the
occasional outdoor hot tub scene wood
fires and turtlenecks some marijuana and
monopoly washed down with the dark red i
don't even ski but if i ever start it's
to be able to live in that dumb and
dumber aspen type scene oh absolutely
somebody asked me uh recently asked me
if i skied and i said i told him that
story how i when i was in
i was in utah with jay lawhead and we
stayed an extra day and went skiing um
up in uh where did they do that film
festival
sundance we were up around there we went
skiing up there and it was great but i i
don't like skiing i love the workout
and i love all that aspect that you're
talking about like uh coming down they
got the fire going and you're drinking
beers dude it's [ __ ] awesome but i
have just never participated in a more
blow your knee out [ __ ] sport than
skiing
but uh just your description there like
that right there is why i want to go
um
it's [ __ ] it's just it's yeah it's
the [ __ ]
who's that guy that guy there the guy in
holland there you are the six foot two
180 187 pounds there you go go skiing
go skiing this is what you should be
doing instead of [ __ ] staring at
yourself in the mirror going i'm ugly
i'm too skinny [ __ ] that do this [ __ ]
you know what i want to buy all the
skiing [ __ ] and not go skiing
and then just go on the treadmill and
get all sweaty and then put the skiing
[ __ ] on and just act like i [ __ ] came
off the mountain
wash it down with a dark red how good
does that sound at 7 34 am to me
all right that's the podcast uh what is
my take on that like i i think that
this is what i would do take skiing
lessons
something i never did
i was like whatever i play hockey dude i
[ __ ] skate
it's the same [ __ ] nobody's trying to
hit you right
you don't realize that there's trees you
forget that which is like the uh
i can't it's like a [ __ ] defenseman
times like 9 million
you never win in that context you never
knock the [ __ ] tree over you
basically die like sonny bono or some
[ __ ] um
i just hate when you fall and like one
of your skis is going one way and the
other is going the other way and it's
never a convenient
[ __ ] way you always feel like you're
gonna [ __ ] blow out an acl but if you
survive
and you get down that hill a couple of
times you know what's funny about skiing
i always love when you get to that point
where you know you're exhausted and you
try to do one more [ __ ] run
and you get up there and you're so tired
by you get halfway down you just fall
down
every third time you try to make a turn
like whatever that [ __ ] acid is that
builds up in your muscles and your legs
you just you're just completely gassed
and you're laughing and your friends
laughing at you and you just get down to
the [ __ ] mountain
you get to the ski lodge hopefully
there's not a bunch of [ __ ] taking up
the whole thing
you know that rich family that has five
kids and it can afford to buy them all
ski stuff despite the fact that they're
all growing and [ __ ]
um you resent them they look like the
kennedys you're like look at those
[ __ ] blue-blooded [ __ ] but if you
can somehow get yourself a seat ah [ __ ]
i want to go i'm going
i'm calling up la head i'm going to go
skiing over the christmas break [ __ ]
this
i'm going
jesus christ did that person paint a
picture or what i'm [ __ ] going
all right
and that is the end of the podcast
and um i got i got to thank everybody
who came out to my shows in europe i
have to thank all the promoters
who got me out there uh i got to thank
everybody who took me out
you know to the bars
to that premier league game to to to
all these sites all the to the lagoon
all the stuff i i can't even like it was
absolutely i'll never forget that tour
um and i'm just going to keep going over
there it was just an unbelievable
experience to end an unbelievable year
where i had some of the biggest shows in
my career
i did the most shows the most cities
i've ever done i did the red state tour
i did that bus tour through the south
with all my buddies and um
jason lawhead and his legendary father
jim lawhead
um
just all the people i got to meet man it
was just the exact reason why i got in
this business was to have fun in a
travel and make people laugh and i
really
i did that this year like i i don't know
it just went to a whole other level i
don't know i can top it next year i'm
[ __ ] exhausted but i'm tired in a
great way so um
thank you to everybody and uh
that's it man i hope you guys enjoy your
uh merry christmas happy kwanzaa happy
hanukkah happy new year hope you guys
have a nice christmas break
and um
like i said man
[ __ ]
if you can scrape together some quarters
get your ass on a plane and go travel i
wish i did it when i was younger and i'm
an old [ __ ] man 45 he never too
never too old to do it so i want that
for all you guys man i hope you guys
have a great successful 2014 that's the
podcast go [ __ ] yourselves
and uh i'll talk to you next week